Moin, Leute.
Keck-Browse.
Wie?
Mein GIF geht nicht.
Mein GIF ist kaputt.
Das sollte eigentlich das Keck-Browse-GIF sein.
Was ist da los?
Sekunde.
Keck-Browse.
Ach, weil es Web-P ist.
Web-P kann das, glaube ich, nicht.
Und wisst ihr, was noch schlimmer ist?
Das FFM-Pack seit Jahren kein Web-P in GIF.
Sorry, sorry.
In GIF.
Konvertieren kann.
Keck-Browse.
Schauen wir mal kurz, ob das Web-P abspielen kann.
Nein, das kann kein Web-P.
Web-P ist broken.
Broken AF.
Was ist da los? Warum?
Da muss ich ein...
Das gibt es nicht als GIF?
Das hier vielleicht als GIF?
Ist das ein GIF?
Das ist ein GIF, oder?
Keck-Browse.
Sekunde.
Jetzt müssen wir jetzt checken, ob das ein GIF ist.
Keck-Browse.
Es ist ein...
GIF.
Funktioniert.
Hendrix, danke schön für den Sub.
Keck-Browse.
Ey, das...
Ohne Scheiß, die Hälfte an Emotes sind bei uns Keck-Emotes.
Also auch meine Overlays.
Keck-Browse.
Keck-Alu.
Keck-W.
Keck-Weight.
Keck-Love.
Keck-W mit Mütze auf.
Keck-Weight.
Original-Keck-W.
Ich muss sagen, Lul3D und Lul ist etwas unterrepräsentiert hier.
Dabei muss ich sagen, eigentlich so im Herzen muss ich sagen, Lul-W ist immer noch das beste Lachen-Emote.
Dein Drucker ist kaputt.
Ja, Laserdrucker kaufen.
Dann hast du nicht diesen Scheiß mit Tinte.
Kein Gamescom-Event gemeinsam.
Ist das jetzt?
Moment.
Ich dachte, die Games...
Ich dachte, das ist erst morgen.
Man kann es ja verdammt sehen, das Gamescom-Event ist eh Residenz-Sleeper.
Guck ich mir nicht an.
Erfreuen wir uns lieber an ein paar schlecht geschriebenen Stellenanzeigen.
Oder wollt ihr das Gamescom-Event gucken?
Dann geh ich wieder auf.
Keck und spiel Runde weiter.
Bald los geht's.
So, jetzt machen wir den ganzen Krempli erstmal wieder zu.
Zack, zack, zack, zack.
Zack.
Package-Update.
So muss es sein.
Zack, alles weg hier.
Package-Update.
Zack.
Kein Gamescom-Event mehr.
Bin ich auch.
Gamescom geht mir so am Arsch vorbei mittlerweile.
Ich mein, ich war ja da ein paar Mal.
Und das war auch ganz cool.
Wobei es mir die letzten ein, zwei Jahre richtig auf den Sack geht.
Deswegen bin ich auch nicht mehr hin.
Was die Experten zu den Anforderungen sagen.
Welche Anforderungen?
Willst du uns eine Stellenanzeige schicken und wir sollen drauf gucken?
Schick her, wenn du irgendwas hast.
Max, was hast du für ein Abschlussprojekt gemacht in der Ausbildung, wenn ich fragen darf?
Das darfst du fragen.
Ich hab das nämlich schon öfters erzählt.
Ich hab sogar ein komplett eigenes Video zugemacht, falls du das noch nicht kennst.
Kennst du meinen YouTube-Channel?
Sehr free.
Ich vermute mal, weil viele sind von YouTube da.
Aber nicht alle.
Nicht alle.
Also...
Wenn du das genau wissen willst, guckst du auf YouTube.
Ansonsten erzähl ich dir das jetzt.
Weil die Leute keinen Bock auf Gamescom-Event haben, wie es ausschaut.
Ich hab gesagt, ich kann auch aufgehen und Baldur's Gate 3 weiterspielen.
Chico, was ist denn jetzt los?
So, ich bin wieder da.
Also, wo bin ich stehen geblieben?
Kannst du einen 4K-Monitor empfehlen?
Nee, ich hab selbst keinen 4K-Monitor.
Ich hab einen 4K-Fernseher, aber keinen 4K-Monitor.
Ja, also Abschlussprojekt.
Was hab ich gemacht?
Äh...
Frage ich mal andersrum.
Was hast du dir denn so vorgestellt?
Was hast du dir denn schon so ausgemalt?
Aber ich erzähl dir erst mal, was ich gemacht hab.
Ich hab ein VPN gebaut.
Und zwar ein Layer 2 VPN.
Für die Telefonanlage.
Es war...
Also eigentlich war das nur ein Beiprodukt, dass es für die Telefonanlage auch geht.
Layer 2 VPN.
Aber...
Letztendlich ist gar nicht so wichtig, dass du ein super kompliziertes Projekt machst.
Also rein von der technischen Seite aus.
Das Projekt muss nicht kompliziert sein.
Du musst die nicht mit technischer...
Tja, wie soll ich sagen?
Technischem Tiefgang beeindrucken bei der IHK.
Die wollen so ein paar...
Die wollen so ein paar Punkte sehen.
Und...
Das wissen viele Leute nicht.
Beziehungsweise haben...
Haben sich nicht irgendwie schlau gemacht.
Weil...
Du musst die...
Wie gesagt.
Du musst die IHK nicht mit technischer...
Irgendwie...
Tiefgreifender Expertise beeindrucken.
Sondern...
Du musst die IHK...
Du musst für die IHK das machen, was die IHK sehen will.
Und das ist...
Ein bisschen Technik.
Ein bisschen BWL.
Das heißt, am besten ist...
Du denkst dir irgendwas aus, was du gerne machen würdest.
Sagst dann aber nicht...
Dass du das genau machst.
Ja, das ist genau das.
Das ist richtig.
Das...
Genau so musst du das machen.
Richtig.
Das sage ich auch in meinem Video.
Ich habe ein paar Videos dazu.
Also...
Ich glaube...
Hallo Leute.
Wo ich die Story von meiner Abschlussprüfung erzähle...
Ist hier.
Ich weiß aber nicht, ob ich dort was zu meinem Abschlussprojekt erzähle.
Genau.
Musst du mal gucken.
Schade, dass...
Das Venice Unleashed abgekackt ist als Projekt.
Äh...
Das Battlefield...
Battlefield 3 ohne...
Ohne...
Diesen Blauschleier.
Und mit ein bisschen anderer Beleuchtung teilweise.
War so mega nice.
Hat sich...
Hat sich so gut gespielt.
Leider hatten die ein paar Memory Leaks.
Und haben sie nicht gefixt.
Und haben auch...
Die letzten Spieler sind abgehauen.
Ja, schade.
Ähm...
Ja.
Also das ist...
Das ist gut.
Wenn du das...
Wenn du das machst.
So.
Also du musst eine Produktauswahl machen.
Das finden die mega gut.
Ich meine...
Müssen musst du nix.
Aber ich habe auch eine Produktauswahl gemacht.
Am besten ist...
Du weißt schon, was du machen willst.
Und rein zufällig...
Gewinnt dann das, was du eh machen willst.
In der Produ...
In der Produktauswahl.
Aber...
Äh...
Also...
Denk nicht, dass du es jetzt komplett...
Besser...
Sogar anders...
Anders gesagt...
Du solltest es nicht übertreiben.
Wenn du eine Produktauswahl machst...
Heißt es nicht, dass du zusätzlich noch einen finalen produktiven Aufbau dieses Produkts
machen musst.
Ja?
Du kannst ja im Rahmen der Produktauswahl durchaus mal zwei, drei Testinstallationen...
Vortäuschen.
Du musst das ja nicht mal wirklich machen.
Das muss halt danach aussehen, als hättest du es gemacht.
Ähm...
Und danach kannst du...
Wenn...
Wenn es dir dann immer noch nicht ganz reicht vom Umfang her...
Kannst du ja...
Kannst du ja irgendwie...
Noch was weiteres mit der Testinstallation machen.
Zumindest...
Es ist nicht Sinn und Zweck der Sache, dass du im Vorfeld halt schon irgendwas Fertiges
hast.
Aber du kannst es natürlich beeinflussen.
Das heißt, wenn du...
Wenn du...
PRTG, Nagios und Checkmk miteinander vergleichen willst und du willst schon mal jeden...
Du willst schon mal...
Also...
Ich weiß ja nicht.
Was willst du denn, dass gewinnt?
Wenn du willst, dass PRTG gewinnt, sagst du ganz einfach Anforderung ist Windows.
Beziehungsweise...
Du sagst nicht Anforderung ist Windows.
Das wäre nämlich Threehead, wenn du sagst Anforderung ist Windows.
Du kommst zu dem Schluss...
Am Aus...
Am Ende der Produktauswahl, dass Windows in eure gesamte Systemlandschaft einfach besser
reinpasst.
Deswegen wird es PRTG.
Falls du da Bock drauf hast.
Ist ja...
Ich...
Ich würde ja lieber den Job wechseln, anstatt dass ich PRTG machen müsste.
Auf Windows only.
Aber das ist natürlich was anderes.
Wenn du jetzt Nagios und Checkmk vergleichst, naja, da kannst du PRTG schon mal gleich rausstreichen,
weil nicht Windows.
Stimmt.
Check...
Du hast Recht.
Ja.
Ich glaube...
Ich glaube, theoretisch läuft sogar Nagios und Checkmk beides unter Windows.
Stimmt.
Ich...
Ich glaube sogar, das geht.
Wer auch immer von allen guten Geistern verlassen ist und das macht.
Ja.
Umgedreht.
Wenn es Linux-mäßig sein soll, dann gibt es ja nur die 2.
Da fällt PRTG flach.
Was...
Was willst du denn, dass es wird?
Jetzt...
Ich kann euch das an der Stelle übrigens auch nochmal sagen.
Also ich habe ja meine Abschlussprüfung gemacht mit einem Projekt, wo ich ein Layer 2 VPN
aufgebaut habe.
Und ich habe auch so eine Auswahlmatrix gemacht.
Mit OpenVPN...
Boah, was war es denn nochmal?
Ich weiß es gar nicht.
IPsec, OpenVPN...
Keine Ahnung.
Es waren mindestens 3 Sachen.
Ich glaube sogar 4.
So, die habe ich über...
Die Sachen habe ich halt gegenübergestellt.
Und da habe ich Plusse, einfache Plusse, doppelte Plusse, neutral, Minus, Minus und so verteilt
in der Tabelle.
Am Ende kam dann raus, dass...
Oh Wunder!
Wer hätte das gedacht?
OpenVPN.
Ja.
OpenVPN gewonnen hat.
So und dann habe ich mit OpenVPN noch so eine Testinstallation gemacht, ob das denn
auch so wirklich dann funktioniert.
Und dann muss ich mich jetzt mal outen an der Stelle.
Ich habe mein Abschlussprojekt gar nicht so umfangreich gemacht, wie ich es in der Abschlussdokumentation
und auch in meiner Präsentation dargestellt habe.
Ich habe viel weniger gemacht, als ich letztendlich da wichtig getan habe in der Doku zu.
Aber...
Da geht es gar nicht so sehr darum.
Wichtig ist, dass du weißt.
du redest dass das ein überzeugendes projektes hat das über wahrscheinlich haben dass die wenigsten
werde gerade docker multistage bild das ist ja echt bock ich frage mich was ist da groß zu
lernen gibt du schreibst halt anstatt einmal docker anweisungen zweimal docker anweisungen
in einem docker fall und das letzte ist das image was rausfällt oder was gibt's da groß
zu lernen homogenität das netzwerk sicherstellen da hätte ich jetzt absolut keine ahnung was du
mir damit sagen willst also als als ihk prüfer ich meine ich kann mir schon was ich kann da
schon was rein interpretieren willst halt dass das netzwerk so mit mehr oder weniger
so gleichartig aufgebaut ist ja wie sie laut die musik oder was ist hier los ja besser ja
was auch der grund ist warum ich privat kein bock auf check mk habe und ganz
ehrlich ich habe jetzt auf meinem aktuellen job bisschen check mk kennengelernt weil die
da noch eine ganz ganz alt gediente also nicht von der version her aber die gibt es schon lange
alt gediente check mk installation hat und ich muss ehrlich sagen also irgendwie ist alles
monitoring kacke ganz ehrlich das was noch am erträglichsten ist ist wenn so metriken geht
finde ich ist prometheus wobei in dem bereich gibt es tatsächlich sogar paar ganz brauchbare
sachen aber das sind sie aus cool
monitoring sachen es ist alles irgendwie kacke check mk fühlt sich an wie von 2005 irgendwie
dann hast du dann hast du zabbix zabbix an sich ist eigentlich ganz cool aber unglaublich
ressourcen hungrig und dann gibt es noch ja old school nagios was ist ja in der variante gar nicht
mehr gibt neu dann hast du gibt es sonst noch so senso und so zeug was kassau benutzt es alles kacke
ich finde das beste was es gibt tatsächlich ist prometheus aber prometheus ist halt nicht
unbedingt dafür gemacht so dieses klassische monitoring zu machen du guckst von außen die
eine kiste an ist die ab oder down das geht alles aber du merkst dass das halt viel selbst gebastelt
ist prometheus ist richtig geil zur metriken einsammeln und dann irgendwelche grafen mit
grafana drüber machen aber alles andere ist halt wieder das monitoring system selbst gebaut
ach so machte monitoring auswahl monitoring auswahl das ist ein sehr das ist eine sehr gute
projektidee macht das monitoring auswahl monitoring tool auswahl du musst aber ein bisschen technik
machen einfach nur einfach produkt also du kannst ja drei oder zwei oder drei tests installation
machen im set 3 tools machst du minimale tests installation du musst dir halt noch kriterien also
das ist ja so eine produktauswahl ist ja nicht so einfach gemacht du musst da nicht am ende bewerten
du musst ja am anfang auch noch erst mal testen und dann kannst du dann auch noch testen und dann
erklären nach welchen kriterien du das ganze auswählt dann gab es irgendwelche showstopper
blablabla ist das nach drei jahren wahrscheinlich auch easy hin aber nicht macht das macht monitoring
auswahl das ist super abschlussprojekt also muss natürlich wie gesagt produkt auswahl mit mit 33
tests installation und dann bewertet du das ganze das ist vom umfang her gut das ist von der mischung
und informatikern gut und ist vieles drin was die IHK sehen will kannst du schon mal darauf einstellen
dass du eine abschlussprüfung gefragt wirst sagen sie mal auf welcher schicht des osi modells
operiert eigentlich check MK dann denkt man sich dann nur was ist das für eine bescheuerte frage
ergibt eigentlich überhaupt keinen sinn aber so fragen kommen dann immer dran wurde ja auch was
zum osi modell gefragt in der abschlussprüfung was ist das denn dead eye zeigt mal hier was haben wir denn da können wir uns gleich anschauen was haben wir denn da können wir uns gleich anschauen
gucken. Ich habe nämlich noch gar nicht angefangen.
Musst du auch hin und wieder mal
neue Kollegen einlernen?
Ne, die müssen mich einlernen
gerade. Wobei ich finde,
das Einlernen hält sich eigentlich in Grenzen.
Ich bin jetzt seit
fast
4 oder 5 Monaten da.
Runden wir mal die Woche auf.
Und
also außer die ersten paar Wochen
hielt es sich doch echt stark in Grenzen.
Das liegt aber auch daran, dass ich zum größten
Teil an
glücklicherweise an der ganzen internen Sache
vorbeikomme, weil ich hauptsächlich Google und Cloud
mache. Äh, Moment.
Du kannst die doch auch
einlernen aus dem Homeoffice.
An den ersten paar Tagen soll gefälligst
euer Chef da sein, dafür sorgen, dass die ihr Notebook,
ihren Arbeitsplatz und sonst was kriegen.
Und ansonsten könnt ihr euch ja abwechseln.
Ihr könnt ja einmal die Woche Ansprache vor Ort machen.
So die Sachen zusammen zeigen. Das haben wir
auch alles Remotes über Teams gemacht.
Überhaupt kein Problem.
Also wenn ich vor Ort dafür
sein müsste, würde es mich auch abfacken.
Ansonsten habe ich das eigentlich immer ganz gerne
gemacht, weil ihr kennt
mich so. Ich rede halt manchmal
ganz gern über Zeug, was mich interessiert.
Und dementsprechend fand ich es auch immer gut, wenn mir
dann einfach Leute drei Stunden am Stück zuhören mussten.
Salto Freak,
danke für den Sub.
Danke an die ganzen anderen Leute, die ich schon übersehen habe.
Übrigens, Leute. Ich habe gesehen, irgendwie ist
das bei Twitch sehr
merkwürdig, ja. Wenn ihr hier
am Start seid
und euch gefällt der Stream,
nein,
ich will euch nicht schiebelten zum Subscriben.
Das könnt ihr natürlich auch machen, weil es ist ja bald wieder
erster, ne? Und so. Ne, das wollte ich gar nicht
sagen. Wenn ihr öfters dabei sein wollt,
wenn ihr euch das Ganze gefällt, könnt ihr auch einfach followen.
Weil
irgendwie ist Twitch komisch, ja.
Ein paar Streams im Folge geht's
dann hoch, teilweise bis zu 15,
16 Follows per Stream.
Und dann mache ich mehr oder weniger
genau das Gleiche, genau das Gleiche
in die gleiche Richtung, nächste paar Streams.
Und die sind dann ein bisschen
Plus und teilweise Minus. Ich verstehe
die Twitch-Logik nicht so genau. Also, das heißt,
wenn euch mein Content gefällt, wenn euch der Stream
gefällt, wenn ihr mir gerne beim
Schwätzen zuhört, beim Basteln zuguckt, dann könnt
ihr mir auch an der Stelle followen.
Und neben dem,
dass das für Twitch nice ist,
dann
freue ich mich auch drüber.
So. Musst du ja
gerade mal in den Stream-Manager gucken.
Gut. Ne, gehst du noch auf den
Gamescom-Livestream? Ne, das juckt mich überhaupt nicht.
Ich gucke mir vielleicht mal eine Zusammenfassung
morgen an. Aber ganz ehrlich,
komm, was war das Letzte
wirklich Coole, was auf der Gamescom angekündigt
wurde?
Damals, es gab neue
Overwatch-Sachen und
das Jahr davor gab
es,
wie hieß diese World of Warcraft,
das World of Warcraft Add-On
mit den Demon Hunters?
Nicht Shadowlands. Shadowlands war das,
was alle kacke fanden.
Ich spiele kein WoW,
deswegen habe ich das schon wieder vergessen.
Legion? Das kann sein.
Ja, Legion, das meine ich.
Genau, das wurde dort angekündigt.
Und das war tatsächlich ganz cool.
Wisst ihr,
das ist auch,
das waren ja auch noch Zeiten, wo ich auf der Gamescom war.
Natürlich ist das alt.
Also,
ich muss sagen, da hatte ich echt Glück.
Das war wahrscheinlich noch so
das und Overwatch-Neuigkeiten.
Das war wahrscheinlich noch so der letzte
Hauch, den man mal
live bei so einer Veranstaltung von Blizzard
spüren konnte, wie die Fanboys,
abgingen und die Atmosphäre.
Das war schon cool.
Ich glaube, heute gibt es da kaum noch was übrig.
Da gibt es da kaum noch was übrig von
Security-Awareness.
Was willst du da für die PRK-Prüfung machen?
Ich schule
Leute, dass sie keine USB-Sticks
anstecken sollen.
Was ist eurer Meinung nach
ein guter Einsteiger-PC,
mit dem man schon was machen kann
auf Low-Budget-Niveau?
Ehrlich gesagt,
ich habe keinen krassen
Geheimtipp.
Also willst du
selbst bauen oder willst du fertig kaufen?
Weil was ich ganz gut finde,
was ich mir für eine
Emulator-Gaming-Geschichte
Hä?
Ja.
Was ich mir für eine Emulator-Kiste
zusammengebastelt habe,
also was ich zusammengebastelt habe, fertig gekauft,
so ein Teil.
Ein UM690.
Den gibt es auch noch in kleineren Ausführungen.
Und der ist natürlich leistungsmäßig
auch enorm gut.
Aber grafisch gut, also für das,
das ist mehr oder weniger das gleiche,
was in der PS5 drin ist.
Naja, nicht wirklich.
Ist schneller als was in der PS5,
aber vom Stil her so ein bisschen das,
was in der PS5 drin ist.
Hat aber eine bessere CPU.
Das ist nice.
Das ist zwar jetzt nicht das Billigste,
aber wenn du sowas Kleines, Kompaktes haben willst,
was ordentlich Wumms hat,
sind die Dinger nicht schlecht.
Aber ganz ehrlich, für den Preis kriegst du sicherlich
auch schon was deutlich Besseres.
Gerade wenn du selbst zusammenbauen willst.
Ja, ist auch alles Mist.
Firewall Monitoring in Prometheus.
Das ist gut.
Das ist auch ein gutes Abschlussprojekt.
Man muss bei der IHK allerdings immer gucken,
dass man halt,
du musst halt ein bisschen BWL und
Business-Kram mit reinkriegen.
Sonst kann es ja halt passieren,
dass die IHK es gleich ablehnt.
So, dann gucken wir uns das jetzt doch mal an.
Du musstest das OSI-Modell auswendig,
Moment, das OSI-Modell auswendig.
Ach du Scheiße.
Also was ich mir nur immer merken kann,
ist, please do not throw Salam.
Salami-Pizza away.
Oder war das so?
Please do not throw Salami-Pizza away.
Doch, ich glaube, das war das.
Das heißt, okay, Chatge,
lass mal kurz überlegen.
Das OSI-Modell von unten nach oben,
also von 1 bis 7.
Physical?
Oh, den zweiten kann ich mir immer nicht merken.
Das ist halt
WiFi und Ethernet und sowas.
D, Data.
Data, Data Link oder sowas.
Data Link Layer.
Also Physical Layer, Data Link Layer.
Network.
Transport.
Session.
Session, 5 ist Session, genau.
7 ist Application.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was 6 ist.
Ah, nee.
Please do not throw Salami-Pizza.
P.
Okay, ich habe keine Ahnung,
was der sechste Layer im OSI-Modell ist.
Presentation Layer.
Kacke, Mann, ey.
So ein Schrott, Mann.
Hättet ihr alles gewusst?
Hättet ihr alles aus dem Kopf gewusst?
Jetzt kommt der Chat natürlich wieder und sagt,
ja, Max, selbstverständlich.
Ich weiß das alles.
Natürlich.
Layer 8 ist der Vermonitor, ja.
Hatte Monitoring als Thema
und als Frage dann SMTP.
Ach, ich habe SNMP gelesen.
SMTP und Fragen zu API-Swirl-Integration
in Ticketsystem.
Ja, die saugen sich teilweise bei der,
bei der Abschlussprüfung
richtig hartes Zeug aus den Fingern.
Weißt du, was mit dem Wort von Sonntagabend passiert ist?
Du meinst Svelte?
Ja, den habe ich gelöscht.
Ich habe IP-Leaked und ein paar andere Sachen.
Aber wenn du was Spezielles wissen willst,
dann kannst du natürlich fragen.
Salto Freak,
Dankeschön für den Sub, Leute.
Pog.
Exzellente Subscription.
Oder wie es mein Englischlehrer
früher gesagt hätte,
Subscribation.
Subscribierung.
Der war ja wirklich der Meinung,
dass Subscription auf Deutsch
Subscribieren heißt.
Dann, dann subskribiert mal.
Ja, habe ich ja gerade schon beantwortet.
Follower, Follower.
Gag Business.
Wir können dein,
wir, wir,
ich lasse mich in, in, in,
lässt du dich auch in Exposure bezahlen?
Wir können dein
GitHub-Projekt bewerben.
Wo kann ich,
wo kann ich am besten Python-Entwickler
Senior-Level zur Festanstellung finden?
Ehrlich gesagt,
ich, ich wollte es gerade sagen.
Mach dir einen LinkedIn-Account.
In Deutschland ist Xing auch recht beliebt,
aber LinkedIn ist eher the way to go.
Mach dir einen LinkedIn-Account und schreib,
du bist Senior Python-Entwickler
und, und schreib halt ein bisschen Zeug rein.
Und das Allerwichtigste bei LinkedIn.
Mach dir,
mach dir ein Anime-Avatar.
Da kriegst du noch mehr Anfragen.
Es kann aber auch sein,
dass Link,
dass LinkedIn sagt,
bitte bestätigen Sie Ihre Identität.
Das sind Sie gar nicht.
Na ja, ansonsten war das eigentlich nicht so.
Aber ich habe es die letzten paar Male,
wo ich gestreamt habe,
gemerkt, so ich mache exakt das Gleiche.
Sag mal für,
wir machen das gleiche Thema für vier Streams so.
Mit ein bisschen Unterbrechung.
Und erster Stream gibt,
gibt keine Ahnung,
plus 15 Follower.
Nächster Stream,
das Gleiche,
minus 5 Follower.
So,
und dann minus 5 Follower,
der nächste wieder plus 10 Follower.
So ganz weird, Champ.
Gut, mag bestimmt auch ein bisschen an der Zeit liegen und alles.
Aber irgendwie verstehe ich das,
verstehe ich das System nicht so ganz.
Aber ist mir nicht so,
ist nicht so,
als würde ich jetzt permanent auf der Statistik gucken.
Ich habe nur letztens reingeguckt,
ist mir aufgefallen,
dass es irgendwie sehr merkwürdig ist,
wie das schwankt.
Ach Moment,
du suchst Leute.
Ich dachte,
ich dachte, du suchst einen Job.
Tja, das ist schwierig,
Leute zu finden.
Ich meine,
wenn du keine Stellenanzeige schaltest,
dann wirst du keine Leute finden.
Und wenn,
und ob die Leute gut sind,
das musst du ja bewerten dann.
Aber viel wichtiger ist erstmal,
dass du eine halbwegs attraktive
Stellenanzeige zusammenzimmerst,
die die Leute anspricht.
Und vergiss,
und vergiss den Obstkorb nicht.
Du kannst natürlich auch hier mal im Chat posten,
Gehaltsspanne und Region.
Wir haben ein paar richtige
Python-Pfeifert-Leute hier im Chat.
Vielleicht.
Also,
ich kann dir eine Sache sagen.
Wenn du ganz gut,
wenn du ganz gut bezahlst,
dann schreib zumindest mal eine Gehaltsspanne
mit in die Stellenanzeige.
Das machen zu wenige.
Und ich finde,
das hat auch einen sehr guten,
das wirkt sehr anziehend.
Ja.
Wenn die Leute auch gleich wissen,
dass da ordentlich was zu holen gibt.
Wie du für ein Aufwachstreben.
Toxische Welt der Software-Entwicklung.
Ganze 55 Views.
Aber der Tim macht gute Videos.
Da haben wir schon ein paar Mal geguckt.
So.
Das soll man sagen.
Ich mache jetzt auch mal schnell den Chat durch.
Die CT hatte letztens sowas auch.
Ja, aber ich glaube,
es gibt mittlerweile bessere Möglichkeiten,
als sich davon eine CT zu kaufen.
Gibt es eigentlich irgendwie ein Bild von einem Home,
was ist HO?
Home Automation?
Das ist nicht HA?
Was meinst du?
Home Assistant?
Home Office?
Ne.
Davon gibt es kein Bild.
Mein Schreibtisch ist auch viel zu unordentlich,
dass ich das fotografieren will.
Gute Frage.
Wahrscheinlich.
Aber schnell ist wieder das Nächste.
Dann hast du Glück gehabt.
Also IHK lehnt auch mal ganz gerne Sachen ab,
wenn im Vorfeld schon klar ist.
Und das ist jetzt nicht einfach nur,
weil ich das random sage.
Das ist einfach nur,
Das ist nicht einfach nur,
weil ich das random sage.
Das ist einfach nur,
Keine Ahnung, drei Windows-Server und da drauf dann, was weiß ich, ein Ticketsystem oder so.
Das mag die IHK nicht.
Da hast du Glück, Jira ist noch eines der besseren Ticketsysteme.
Ich muss sagen, ich finde Jira eigentlich vollkommen in Ordnung.
Wie seht ihr das?
Also ich muss sagen, alle anderen Sachen gingen mir bisher mehr auf den Sack als Jira.
Das einzige Problem bei Jira ist, wenn das jeweilige Unternehmen total verkonfiguriert.
Atrix 42, gibt es das noch? Wobei das ja der Hersteller ist.
Nein, das ist nicht ernst gemeint.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ein Anime-Bild auf LinkedIn besonders gut ankommt.
Auf der anderen Seite, eventuell, vielleicht hilft es ja auch genau denjenigen anzusprechen, der den perfekten Job für dich hat.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber eigentlich machen sie auf LinkedIn ansonsten alles immer so super seriös.
Und eine Sache, die ich auf LinkedIn ja immer ein bisschen lächerlich finde, ich gucke da immer noch bei meiner alten Firma rein, wo ich vorher gearbeitet habe.
Und...
Ich finde es immer geil, dass auf LinkedIn...
Also auf LinkedIn sind so krass viele Selbstdarsteller.
Ich gucke da manchmal noch rein und da posten dann irgendwelche Projektleiter und sowas.
Ich muss es jetzt anonymisieren, aber...
So ganz cringige Sachen.
Nach dem Motto, deutsche Finanzbranche und Top-IT.
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Ich selber nicht.
Aber seit ich bei XY bin, habe ich festgestellt...
Nicht nur Microsoft und Google können Top-IT.
Nein!
Äh, bla bla bla kann auch Top-IT.
Und so...
Oh, das ist so cringe, das zu lesen, Alter.
Also, auf LinkedIn habe ich echt den Eindruck, manche posten dann nur irgendwelche Blog-Artikel rein zur Selbst- und Huldigung und zum Schleim beim aktuellen Arbeitgeber.
Wurde deine Stelle schon besetzt bei deinem neuen Arbeitgeber...
Bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber?
Also...
Ob es meine Stelle direkt...
Direkt war, weiß ich nicht.
Aber ja, wurde sie.
Allerdings, sie haben niemand gefunden.
Und jetzt haben sie...
Haltet euch fest.
Gleich klippen, dass ihr Racism posten könnt auf Twitter.
Nee, ernsthaft.
Haltet euch fest.
Ähm, soweit ich das mitbekommen habe, wurde meine Stelle besetzt von einer Inderin, die kaum Deutsch kann.
Und...
Jetzt kommt...
Jetzt kommt der Hit.
Die wurde schon gleich von meinem alten Arbeitgeber instant gescamt.
Zumindest das, was ich so gehört habe.
Nämlich...
Braucht die ja irgendwie für die Aufenthaltsgenehmigung und sowas braucht die ja einen Job mit einer gewissen Dauer.
Und sie haben ihr versprochen, unbefristet einen Job.
Und jetzt haben sie den Job irgendwie nur bis Ende des Jahres befristet oder sowas in der Richtung.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher...
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich das...
Ob ich das...
Alles...
Alles richtig mitbekommen habe.
Ich habe das ja auch nur um drei Ecken gehört.
Aber...
Ganz...
Ganz weirdchampig wieder, was da los.
Was da läuft, ja.
Wahrscheinlich wollten sie die runterhandeln damit.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was da läuft.
Ich sage doch richtig...
Also bei dem Laden wundert mich echt nichts mehr.
Ja, gut, da ist da weg.
Auf Xenon LinkedIn schreiben mich mehr Frauen an, als auf irgendwelche Dating-Apps.
Ähm...
Was schreiben die denn?
Schreiben die dann sowas wie...
Oh...
Ähm...
Dein...
Dein GitHub-Profil macht mich ganz wild oder...
Oder schreiben die nur...
Suche Experte...
Suche Python-Experte.
Biete 35k im Jahr.
Naja, was meint ihr denn, was auf LinkedIn sich rumtreibt?
Da kriegst du teilweise so komische Offer wie...
Ich habe euch das doch erzählt.
Von meinem Kollege, der jetzt auch bei mir arbeitet.
Ich habe euch das doch erzählt, wie sie den versucht haben zu scammen über LinkedIn.
So nach dem Motto...
LinkedIn.
Recruiting-Typ schreibt ihn an.
Mal mal ganz kurze, ganz kurze die Story.
Ja, ich habe die euch glaube ich schon zweimal erzählt.
LinkedIn.
Recruiting-Typ schreibt ihn an und sagt...
Hier, wir suchen hier einen...
Ähm...
Keine Ahnung...
Experten-Admin.
Und...
Gehaltsspanne...
90 bis 105k.
Und...
Da hat er gemeint...
Oh, cool.
Oh, klingt gut.
Da hat er sich dort...
Ah, da hat er sich dort beworben.
Beziehungsweise Recruiter hat das für ihn in die Wege geleitet.
Dann hat er mit denen...
Vorstellungsgespräch gehabt.
Hat mit denen sogar einen...
Wie nennt man sowas?
So einen theoretischen Fall durchgespielt.
So nach dem Motto...
Bei ihnen geht ein Störungsticket ein.
Es handelt sich um die höchste Störungsstufe.
Wie reagieren sie?
Der hat so einen Fall mit denen sogar durchgespielt.
Die hatten drei Vorstellungsgespräche.
Case...
Nee, Case Study ist...
Ich dachte Case Study ist sowas, was die Unternehmen machen, um was besser zu verkaufen.
So mit Testimonials und sowas.
Szenario.
Sowas in der Richtung.
So.
Der hatte 203 Vorstellungsgespräche mit denen.
Und am Ende...
Also es war immer diese 90 bis 105k im Raum.
Und am Ende waren sie sich einig und so.
Alles gut.
Und es wurde ihm auch immer wieder bestätigt.
So.
Und dann ging es darum, so nach dem Motto...
Okay, jetzt lasst uns mal Vertrag fertig machen.
Und dann sagen sie zu ihm...
Ach ja, übrigens...
Die Stelle...
Wir können Ihnen nur 75k anbieten.
Es war leider keine Senior...
Keine Seniorposition mehr...
Im Budget vorhanden.
Das Budget ermöglicht keine Seniorposition mehr.
Und dann hat er auch gesagt...
Okay, keck bei.
Tschüss.
Fragt man sich halt auch, was denken die sich denn dabei?
Denken die sich...
Man fängt irgendwo an, die einen quasi schon vorm Vertrag unterschreiben, verarschen?
Was denken die sich dabei?
Ich verstehe das nicht.
Oder meinen die...
Ah, wenn die unsere Firma erst kennengelernt haben, dann...
Dann...
Dann machen die das auch für 30k weniger, oder wie?
Hä?
Das werde ich nicht verstehen.
Selbstgebautes Ticketsystem.
Der Ticketchamp.
Wird Zeit, Leute.
Angag...
Ich suche keinen neuen Job.
Kennst du dich mit dem SAP Ababaus?
Nein.
Ich habe es auch nicht vorzulernen.
Aber wir haben im Chat ein paar.
Also falls du Leute suchst...
Wir haben im Chat...
Wir machen jetzt...
Wobblons Stellenvermittlung.
Falls du welche suchst...
Schreib mal in Chat.
Wir haben hier Ababa-Experten.
Habe ich schon gesehen.
Hat...
Hat eigentlich...
Wie hieß er denn?
Der mit dem Python-Entwickler.
Hat er noch was reingeschrieben?
Hier.
Blöd, ist wieder weg.
Was kennst du denn für...
Was kennst du denn so für Firmen?
Bei meiner war eigentlich alles top.
Und an Fire Emblem wurde sich auch gehalten.
Also ganz ehrlich, ich glaube weder deine noch meine Samples sind sonderlich hoch.
Das heißt...
Das heißt, kein Eindruck von uns ist jetzt irgendwie repräsentativ für die gesamte Branche.
Bei dir lief alles gut.
Bei mir lief zum größten Teil auch alles gut.
Außer, dass ich keinen Bock mehr auf meinen alten Arbeitgeber hatte.
Aber...
Das...
Das war ja auch nicht von mir.
Ne?
Muss ich sagen.
Das mit diesen...
90-105k und wir bieten ihn jetzt 75.
Das war von dem Kollege, mit dem ich jetzt...
Quasi in der neuen Firma...
Quasi gewechselt bin von den neuen.
Den haben sie verarscht in der Richtung.
Haha.
Ja.
Meinst du, ABAP grenzt schon an Selbstverletzung?
Ja?
Okay.
Auf geht's.
Also.
Das wurde eben geschickt.
Ob ich mir das mal angucken kann.
Wir hatten das geschickt.
Und ist derjenige noch da?
Weil ich hab jetzt ja gefühlt 20 Minuten gelabert, seitdem er das geschickt hat.
Wer war denn das?
Äh...
D-Space.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Das...
Dead...
Dead Eye?
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen...
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen ist das nicht mehr drin.
So lange ist das wahrscheinlich schon her.
Okay.
Auf geht's.
Also.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Ach, Dead Eye.
Wobei...
Sag's mir nachher, okay?
Wenn ich fertig bin mit...
Weil wir hatten hier schon Leute, die Stellenanzeigen gepostet haben.
Aus zwei Gründen...
Oder sagen wir mal so.
Mindestens aus zwei Gründen.
Einmal, weil sie sich drauf bewerben wollen.
Oder zweitens, weil sie der Herausgeber der Stellenanzeige sind.
Aber sag's mir...
Sag's mir erst danach, ja?
20.10 Uhr.
Naja.
Ist halt 25 Minuten her.
Aber es müsste eigentlich noch drinstehen, ne?
Ja.
Warum habe ich eigentlich meine Timestamps ausgeblendet?
Ich finde das immer nicht.
Chat-Aussehen.
Zeitstempel.
Ja.
Es ist nicht mehr drin dabei.
Die Musik kann sich heute echt nicht entscheiden, welche Lautstärke sie haben will.
Okay.
Also.
Gucken wir uns das mal an.
Willkommen bei DSpace.
Start your career.
Softwareentwickler.
Agile.
Excellent.
Da wird direkt diagonal das Skalieren angefangen.
Softwareentwickler.
MWD.
Agile Product-Entwicklung.
Oh.
Da habe ich ja gar keinen Plan von.
Das heißt, ich kann da wirklich nur sehr allgemein was zu sagen.
Kennung.
Schandort.
Paderborn.
Männlich-Weiß-Deutsch.
Natürlich.
Als Softwareentwickler sind sie ein wichtiger Teil unseres...
Okay.
Bla bla bla bla.
Konjunktur.
Okay.
Konfiguration-Desk.
Also ich vermute mal, das ist was, was DSpace herstellt.
Sie können ihr Gespür für Innovationen einbringen, an herausfordernden neuen Features arbeiten
sowie bestehende Funktionalität weiterentwickeln.
Gleichzeitig schaffen sie es, durch ihr sehr gutes Technikverständnis maximale Kundennutzen
zu schaffen.
Wir bieten ihnen eine ansprechende Gelegenheit sich in einem positiven und kreativen Arbeitsumfang
...
Okay.
Ähm.
Bisschen Lob.
Reise am Anfang muss sein.
Ihre Aufgaben.
ständiges gemeinsames programmieren mit kollegen in einem internationalen scrum team wissensaustausch
im team und kontinuierliche weiterentwicklung der eigenen fähigkeiten ist es ein bisschen sehr vage
alles oder bis jetzt zumindest vielleicht kommt ja noch konzeptionierung und implementierung von
features zur nutzerfreundlichen unterstützung von simulink in unseren tools sowie sicherstellung der
produkt der produktqualität durch frühes testen anwenden einer methoden um anwendergerechte
funktioniert iterativ und inkrementell weiterzuentwickeln oder muss aber kurz darauf
eingehen das war nur ein witz mit dem obstkorb das ist das ist das ist so das meme also ganz
ehrlich wenn du pluspunkte sammeln willst in der stellenanschreibung in der stellenbeschreibung
erstellen ausschreibung dann schreibt rein machen den witz über den obstkorb
sagt wir haben bessere vorteile als ein obstkorb oder sowas und dann das macht dich lustig über
den obstkorb das finden die leute gut das haben jetzt pluspunkte und kostenlose getränke auch
ja das ist doch gut das ding ist ich brauche schnell ein paar payson entwickler die bereits
das eine oder andere komplexe projekt abgeschlossen haben und erfahrung mitbringen erfahrung mit ki
wäre von vorteil gehalt 20 bis 90 k ja da kriegst du bestimmt ein paar entwickler für
wenn du
schnell leute brauchst ich meine du hast ja du hast ja im prinzip nur drei varianten wenn du schnell leute brauchst du kannst entweder dich möglichst attraktiv verkaufen beziehungsweise dann muss halt auch dein unternehmen was zu bieten haben du kannst deine eigenen ansprüche runterschrauben oder du kannst die leute mit geld zuschütten realistisch betrachtet wahrscheinlich irgendwie so eine kombination aus allen drei dingen also ich denke für das für das gehalt kannst du durchaus payson entwickler finden es kommt natürlich immer drauf an so ein bisschen die branche und die
region aber ich denke für so aber so wenn man von uns vielleicht richtung 90k bewegen da findest du auch recht schnell willige leute muss das halt gut verkaufen und chat wenn einer interesse hat payson pfeiffer entwickler mit projekterfahrung und eventuell noch ahnung von ki dann könnt ihr euch im chat bei hellenickei melden
wir machen jetzt hier kriege ich eigentlich bei dem ich verdiene ich müsste eigentlich auch was falls wir irgendwie leute vermitteln müsste ich eigentlich auch was dran verdienen oder okay wir jetzt will ich will das andere aber nicht über überbrechen unterbrechen ja aber schreib schreib schreib ruhig mal so ein bisschen was ihr macht ich meine leute fällt es immer schwer sich so ein bisschen zu überwinden wenn sie gar nichts dazu wissen ki finden bestimmt viele leute extrem nice und gehalt von richtung 90k finden bestimmt auch viele leute
also da wirst du wirst du was finden und ich weiß dass wir im chat durchaus die ein oder anderen richtig schlauen payson entwickler haben das weiß ich unter anderem daher weil ich vor ein paar streams was gebastelt habe in payson und nicht so viel plan hatte also mich willst du eher nicht haben und wir hatten im chat einige die kannten sich richtig gut aus zumindest so meinem meiner auffassung nach ja also lass mal weiter gucken
anwenden agiler methoden um anwendungsgerechte funktionen zu schaffen
iterativ und inkrementell weiterzuentwickeln
da könnte man noch ein bisschen continuous integration und delivery und
so droppen auf die das verstehen die leute auch drauf so also na klar ich
vermittle euch alle leute dann muss sie langsam müssen wir mal
vermittlungsprovision reden also ihr profil abgeschlossenes informatik
ingenieur oder verwandtes technisches naturwissenschaftsstudium oder eine
vergleichbare qualifikation sehr gute programmierkenntnisse matlab simulink
oder c sharp und dotnet sowie die bereitschaft sich in die jeweils andere
programmierumgebung 1 das finde ich gut dass das so geschrieben ist so nach dem
motto es muss nicht alles perfekt sein also mit c sharp und dotnet da hätte ich
ahnung von mit von matlab matlab wie auch immer man das überhaupt
richtig ausspricht man will das wahrscheinlich nicht
matlab aussprechen
habe ich keine ahnung hätte ich auch keinen bock drauf gute kenntnis in c und
c++ von vorteil na da wäre die space bei mir aber genau richtig ideale
erfahrung mit microsoft azure devops git microsoft visual studio ja ok passt gut
dazu bereitschaft ein komplexes produkt
portfolio zu lernen und spaß daran herausforderungen in teamarbeit zu
bewältigen
ja ok
gute deutsch und englisch kenntnisse was sie bei uns erwartet wir haben in
einer zukunftssicheren branche internationalen teams mit dem die space
mentoring gewählte ziel sich reinarbeitung ist ja das finde ich auch
immer so ein bisschen merkwürdig also ich hätte warum das viele unternehmen
reinschreiben wahrscheinlich weil viele leute auch schon negative erfahrungen
gemacht haben und festgestellt haben es gibt keine einarbeitung aber ich denke
wir um im umkehrschluss immer ist das nicht eigentlich das ureigenste interesse das jene
jeweiligen unternehmens die leute gescheit einzuarbeiten individuelle
weiterbildung mit flexiblen arbeitszeitmodellen sagen wir eine work
life balance in kooperation mit e-gym wellpass e-gym wellpass das haben das
haben wir glaube ich auf der arbeit auch das kommt mir bekannt vor habe ich aber
nicht einen freiwilligen monatlichen netto-
inflationsausgleich in höhe von 150 euro zahlen wie in zusätzlich zu ihrem
gehalt okay nice wobei ich mir nicht sicher bin ob 150 euro die
inflationsrate aktuell ausgleichen ich mein mann genommen man verdient um
die 100 k damit kann man es einfach rechnen
das heißt im jahr wird das ganze 10 k teurer alles ungefähr das heißt da
müsste es eigentlich 1000 euro inflationsausgleich pro monat geben dass
es ungefähr hinkommt
Die betriebseigene Kiste.
Das ist sehr gut.
Wenn man sowas als Vorteil hat, unbedingt reinschreiben.
Unser D-Space Spirit bei uns sind alle per Du.
Dresscode gibt es nicht.
Ja, okay, das ist auch schon mal nice.
Und kein Obstkorb.
Okay, bevor ich da jetzt mehr im Detail dazu sage.
Dead Eye, willst du dich dort bewerben?
Oder ist das eine Stellenanzeige von euch?
Du bist interessant?
Okay.
Also ehrlich gesagt, ich finde die Serie 0815, da ist jetzt nichts, was für mich irgendwie sonderlich heraussticht.
Sie könnten, sie könnten, also es liest sich Serie 0815.
Leider ein bisschen wenig Details.
Wäre auch ganz interessant, was sie sonst noch für Technologien einsetzen.
Oder vielleicht, wenn es die schafft, oder irgendwie bekannte Frameworks, irgendwas.
Und keine großartigen Informationen zum Thema Homeoffice.
So, das wäre das erste, was mir so einfällt.
Natürlich, wenn du Kinder hast, ist das natürlich ein Riesenargument hier.
Die Stellenanzeige ist ja 0815, ja, das stimmt.
Leute, wenn ihr übrigens noch andere Stellenanzeigen habt, sei es von eurer Firma, wo ihr wissen wollt, was so ein random Dude auf Twitch davon hält.
Oder wenn ihr euch irgendwo bewerben wollt, schickt her.
Ansonsten gehe ich jetzt gleich auf StepStone oder sonst wo und suche mal, was es bei mir in Frankfurt gibt.
Aber wie gesagt, ich sage es noch mal vor die Frage, ich suche aktuell keinen Job.
Ich bin in fünf Monaten der Probezeit.
Ich meine, noch könnte ich, noch könnte ich.
Ja, aber ich habe gar kein Interesse, da abzuhauen, weil bis jetzt bin ich da eigentlich ganz gut.
Ich habe keine, es juckt mich nicht, irgendwie da abzuhauen.
Frag mal, schick mal, schick mal eine E-Mail hin.
Deswegen meinte ich ja, es wird wahrscheinlich eher nicht so ausgesprochen.
Muss man T3-Sub sein?
Irgendwie läuft das für was?
Um vermittelt zu werden.
Das war ein Witz.
Leute, wenn du einen Job suchst und jemand im Chat ist, ja.
Ich habe kein Problem, ein paar Worte zu.
Aber ich habe, ich bin kein professioneller Vermittler oder habe es auch nicht vor zu werden.
Leute, nicht, dass ich auch noch in den Insi-Modus muss demnächst.
Das wäre ja, wäre ja fatal.
Wobei, wobei der Insi-Modus ist doch schon wieder out.
Jetzt sind wir noch krasser Trader in Dubai.
Oder in Dubai, wie die Amis das irgendwie sagen.
Okay.
Warum habe ich den hier?
Ich habe den hier das Image geöffnet eben.
Was?
Zum Beispiel SAP.
Nee, Leute.
Ich will keine SAP-Job suchen.
Wann Halbmarathon?
Ich hätte heute fast neue Bestzeit gehabt, so über 6 Kilometer.
Aber ich musste dreimal stehen bleiben.
Aber nicht, weil ich nicht mehr konnte.
Zweimal wegen Hundegassi gehen.
Und einmal, weil mein Handy nicht mehr funktioniert.
Ich habe das Handy, wie nennt man das, Handy-Gürtel, Handy-Tasche, Handy, wie heißt denn sowas?
Das ist so eine Tasche, die macht man sich so um den Bauch mit, oder besser gesagt, so unter das Hemd unterm Bauch, so, sowas hier, ist gerutscht, die muss sich einstellen.
Laufen, Handy, Tasche, sowas hier.
Ja.
Laufgürtel für Handy.
Der ist gerutscht.
Louis Vuitton-Store, ja.
Gürtelstraße.
Frankfurt-Gürtelstraße.
Louis Vuitton-Store.
Zahl die Kollektion bar.
Pick auf Sponsor.
Einzige Haftbefehl-Lyrics, die ich bemerken kann.
Ja.
So ein Teil ist das.
Und der ist gerutscht.
Da stand ich bestimmt 20, 30 Sekunden rum und hab das wieder enger gemacht und angezogen.
Also wahrscheinlich habe ich heute fast eine Minute oder länger rumgelaufen und rumgelaufen.
Ich habe das Handy dabei, also ich habe so einen Gürtel hier in der Richtung.
Hier mache ich den Schlüssel rein, hier mache ich das Handy rein und dann drehe ich das rum, sodass ich die Schnalle vorne habe und das Ding hier auf dem Rücken.
Das mache ich unter das T-Shirt, das siehst du kaum.
Stecke ich das, das ist ein ziemlich labberiges T-Shirt, stecke ich in die Hose und dann geht's los.
Ich war heute Morgen wieder.
Also ich muss sagen, mittlerweile...
Also ein Vorteil hat das auch, wenn es keine neue Bestzeit gab.
Muss ja nicht immer, geht natürlich auch irgendwie langsam.
Ja, gucken wir uns gleich an.
Also eins muss ich sagen, ich habe mir letztens ein Wie-Jogge-Ich-Richtig-vom-Lauf-Stil-Herr-Video angeguckt.
Und ich muss sagen, das hat wirklich was gebracht.
Ich habe das heute mal...
Heute mal versucht, es soweit umzusetzen.
Deutlich angenehmer, sowohl für die Beine als auch für den Rücken.
Und ich hatte...
Also ich war schneller, mit ein bisschen niedrigerem Puls.
Also das hat sich wirklich gelohnt, das sich mal in Ruhe anzugucken.
Ich nehme das Handy mit, das liegt daran, ich habe zwar eine Fitness...
Ich habe zwar so eine Tracking-Uhr, aber...
Also die zeichnen da auch ohne Handy und sowas auf.
Aber ich will, dass man sieht, wo ich rumlaufe.
Das sieht man nur auf dem Handy, falls irgendwas ist.
Ist es gerade nicht viel zu heiß?
Ich bin heute Morgen um 7 Uhr gelaufen, da war es noch nicht so heiß.
7.30 Uhr, 7.30 Uhr, oder?
Warte mal, ich sage es euch.
Zack, Garmin-App, ich bin gelaufen um 7.46 Uhr.
Und es waren 20 Grad.
Das sieht man da auch.
Es waren 20 Grad.
So, und ich hatte heute...
Meine Kilometerzeiten waren...
Erster Kilometer, 9 Minuten 14.
Das war, wo ich 30 Sekunden oder so, oder 30, 40 Sekunden rumgestanden habe
und mein Handy-Gurt justieren musste.
Zweiter Kilometer, 8.11 Uhr.
Dritter, 8.37 Uhr.
Vierter, 8.18 Uhr.
Fünfter, 8.6 Uhr.
Sechster, 7.18 Uhr.
Da habe ich ein bisschen Gas gegeben.
Also, mein Ziel jetzt erstmal ist, angenehm so die 6 Kilometer laufen können,
ohne dass es mir jetzt irgendwie nervig wird
und gucken, dass ich konstant unter 8 Minuten komme.
Nee, habe ich gerade nicht.
Okay, let's go.
Also, gucken wir uns das mal an.
Element.
Und das da haben wir auch noch, okay.
Also, Software Engineering.
Senior.
Salzburg.
Remote.
Aha, Vollzeit-Teilzeit.
Jetzt passt der männlich-weiß-deutsch-Witz gar nicht mehr, weil...
Salzburg.
Ist in Österreich, oder?
Ja, hab schon.
Spanien.
Wusste ich doch.
Okay.
Also, männlich-weiß-Österreichisch.
Aber ich finde schon mal gut, dass gleich oben drin steht Salzburg...
Äh, nicht Salzburg.
Äh, Remote und Teilzeit möglich.
Das finde ich nice.
Das würde mich persönlich schon mal direkt ansprechen.
Okay, worum geht's?
Die Entwicklung von individuellen E-Commerce-Web-Applications im Business-to-Consumer- und Business-to-Business-Bereich,
wenn ich nicht ganz falsch liege, ist deine Welt.
Da bist du bei uns genau richtig.
Für den Fall der Fälle, dass...
Ich weiß nicht genau, wer die Stellenanzeige gepostet hat, aber...
Für den Fall der Fälle, dass derjenige die Stellenanzeige gepostet hat,
die gepostet hat, weil sie von dem Unternehmen ist, wo er arbeitet...
Ähm...
Ja.
Eternity.
Nee, es ist ja von euch.
Ihr sucht gerade.
Also, ich glaube, ich gette,
ihr wolltet einen coolen, innovativen, sagen wir mal so, Einleitungsspruch machen.
Aber den habe ich in der Art und Weise...
Also, jetzt nicht mit Business-to-Consumer, Business-to-Business...
Aber der ist so 0815, der Spruch.
Ich finde es schon mal gut, dass es nicht anfängt mit...
Wir sind die Elements GmbH und wir sind die Geilsten und einen halben Absatz haben, warum das Unternehmen das Geilste ist.
Es gibt schon mal große Pluspunkte, ja.
Aber der Satz ist wirklich ultra 0815.
Den habe ich in der Variante, keine Ahnung, schon 150 Mal oder so gesehen.
Vielleicht gibt es ja noch irgendwas, was einfach griffiger für euch ist.
Keine Ahnung.
Genau.
Nutzt Twitch-E-Modes.
Dann findet ihr auch die guten Leute.
Aber kommen wir mal zum eigentlichen Kern der Sache.
Warum seid ihr wie verrückt am Cake-Business-Spammen?
Was habe ich verpasst?
Cake-Business?
Cake-Business-Fragezeichen?
Einfach nur so.
Also, was wollen sie denn haben?
Selbstständige Entwicklung von individuellen E-Commerce-Web-Applications.
Okay, ja.
Teamorientiertes, aktives Mitdenken bei Entwurf und Konzeption von neuen Kundenlösungen.
Weiterentwicklung und Betreuung von bestehenden Lösungen.
Wollt ihr da nicht vielleicht Projekten?
Produkte oder sowas hinschreiben?
Oder Applikationen?
Weil wenn es doch schon die Lösung ist, muss man sich auch nicht weiterentwickeln, ne?
Management des gesamten Software-Entwicklungs-Lebenszyklus.
Da fände ich jetzt als Bewerber noch ganz interessant, was ihr darunter versteht.
Weil mir das Einblick gegeben würde, wie das bei euch läuft.
Also sprich, bis zu welchem Zeitpunkt bin ich dafür zuständig?
Bin ich auch für Cloud-Deployments zuständig?
Gibt's ja durchaus Entwickler, die müssen sowas heutzutage machen.
Was ich auch gar nicht schlecht finde.
Ja.
Gibt's, irgendjemand hat denen ein Kubernetes-Cluster hingestellt und die müssen ein paar YAML-Files erstellen und deployen dann ihr Zeug selbst.
Also es wäre tatsächlich ganz interessant zu wissen, was da alles dazu gehört.
Entwicklung von technischen Guidelines und Qualitätssicherung.
Ja, gut.
Passt irgendwo.
Auch wenn ich das jetzt nicht so direkt auf Software-Entwicklung münzen könnte.
Proaktive Mitarbeit an Kernkomponenten.
Und Frameworks sowie Open-Source-Projekten.
Das ist cool.
Das würde ich tatsächlich sogar mal ein bisschen weiter hervorheben.
Weil ich glaube, das macht bei vielen Entwicklern Pluspunkte.
Wäre vielleicht ganz gut, an dem Punkt noch drunter zu schreiben.
So was wie, Elements ist ein großer Open-Source-Contributor.
Zum Beispiel das und das und das.
Finden die Leute wahrscheinlich auch ganz spannend.
Das hast du alles drauf.
Hervorragende Erkenntnisse in PHP.
Oh.
Muss das sein.
Gut, gibt Leute, die mögen PHP.
Sehen wir oft genug auf YouTube, kriegen wir irgendwelche PHP-Videos vorgeschlagen.
Es gibt tatsächlich erstaunlich viele PHP-Begeisterte.
Langjährige Erstellung von Web-Applikationen kann man erwarten bei einem Senior.
Einschläge, Erfahrungen, Datenbanken, MariaDB.
Das ist ja der ganz klassische Web-Stack hier, oder?
PHP MySQL.
Gute Kenntnisse, HTML, CSS und JavaScript.
Guter Umgang mit Linux-Systemen.
Interessant.
Ja.
Das ist ja wirklich ultra-klassisch.
Linux, MySQL, PHP.
Was?
Chat, wer spricht hier von Node?
Es geht doch eindeutig um PHP.
Unsere Tools und Technologien.
PHPStorm.
Oh, damit macht ihr bestimmt Pluspunkte.
GitLab, Gulp.
Ist das nicht so ein...
So ein...
JavaScript-Job-Runner?
...
Elastic Search?
Fragezeichen.
HTML5, Redis, Docker, Git, CSS3, GraphQL.
Ah, okay.
36 Stunden Arbeitswoche.
Kein All-In, und keine Pauschalen?
Da wäre ich jetzt...
Da bin ich jetzt ein bisschen lost, was...
was damit gemeint ist und keine pauschalen chat habt ihr eine idee was damit gemeint
dass er mit überstunden zu tun ach so keine pauschalen ach so ist das gemeint ok überstunden
jaja jetzt versteht office home office oder remote darin kurz ein innovatives umfeld bei
dem aktiven loyalty program details zu allen und benefits findest du hier das ist halt schon ein
bisschen ach so moment also ich hätte ja gesagt das ist eigentlich ganz cool und ich habe keine
ahnung wie das gehaltsgefüge so in in österreich aussieht aber ganz ehrlich für den senior
entwickler 46 k ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen
wenig ich meine für den guten seniorentwickler kann man das doppelte ausgeben also insgesamt
würde ich sagen ist sie schlecht paar sachen habe ich ja schon erzählt was mir ist was mir
zu eigen aufgefallen ist was ich was ich gut finde ist dass ihr euch nicht erst mal selbst
lobpreist irgendwie in einem absatz hier halbe seite ja aber aber insgesamt ich sagen also es
ist sehr lobenswert von euch eine
ein gewalt daran zu schreiben ich weiß das steht ab ich weiß das steht ab allerdings
spätestens seit dsl-anschlüssen sind die leute skeptisch wenn das steht ab weil die leute denken
das ist das minimale in österreich okay das kann sein dass das in österreich anders ist aber
insgesamt muss ich sagen 46 k für den seniorentwickler würde ich jetzt sagen jetzt nicht so wenig aber wenn es nicht so wenig ist dann in den seinen kauf von daumen hoch ist das wahnsinnig gut okay ich bin sehr glücklich aber ich bin schon glücklich über die 3d karte du hast mir ein bisschen verliebt in dieser karte weißt du meines erinnerst dich wie viel kurs des abgelds daraus gemacht hast und noch ein bisschen was man in dem zweiten Phi in der karte macht und was man dann macht in der karte machst und was man auch macht in der
Insgesamt würde ich sagen, 46k für einen Senior-Entwickler würde ich jetzt sagen, ist ein bisschen wenig.
Aber wenn es ein Österreich-Ding ist, dann ignoriere ich das, was ich gesagt habe.
Ich finde es wunderbar, dass das Teilzeitmöglich ist, dass das Homeoffice direkt drin steht.
Remote, Hybrid, alles gut.
Also ich denke, ihr werdet sicherlich den einen oder anderen Bewerber da drauf finden.
Ich würde mir halt ein bisschen ums Gehalt Gedanken machen, aber das ist natürlich,
vielleicht ist es ein Österreich-Ding, dass das eher so ein, weil es gesetzlich erforderlich ist,
halt drin steht und keiner achtet wirklich da drauf.
Keine Ahnung.
Einzigartige Arbeitsatmosphäre, flexibles Arbeit, Body-System.
Well-Being.
Legendäre Firmen-Events.
Oh, da geht bei mir gleich der MonkaS hier.
Geht los.
Aber ist ja gut, solange die Sachen nicht Pflicht sind, kann ja jeder daran teilnehmen, der Bock drauf hat.
Ja.
So sieht's aus.
So, und dann hat doch eben jemand noch was gepostet.
Otto.
Deutscher Otto Lahn.
Ähm, ist Otto nicht pleite?
War da nicht letztens was?
Ach nee, Otto Krupp rutscht in die roten Zahlen.
Nee, die sind noch nicht pleite.
Die machen nur weniger Geld.
Okay, nee, dann ist halb so wild, halb so wild.
Not stonks.
Checkst du nur Entwicklerstelle?
Nee, eigentlich nicht.
Weil ich bin kein Entwickler.
Ich bin froh über irgendwas anderes.
Zu Entwicklerstellen kann ich nur so allgemeines Zeug sagen.
Das ist ja eigentlich mein, mein Fachgebiet.
Auch wenn wir erstaunlich oft Software-Entwicklung machen im Stream, aber nicht womit ich mein Geld verdiene.
Ist eine Pentester-Stelle.
Gucken wir uns auch gleich an.
Reply.
Schauen wir uns gleich an.
Gucken wir uns erst mal Otto an.
Software-Developer.
AWS-Python.
MWD-Vollzeit-Teilzeit-Homeoffice-möglich.
Sehr gut, dass das gleich drinnen steht.
Erschienen vor sechs Tagen.
Gut, ich vermute mal, derjenige, der das gepostet hat, will sich dort bewerben, oder?
Ich weiß nicht, wer es gepostet hat, aber könnt ihr, könnt ihr mal in, oder kannst ja mal in Chat schreiben.
Ich vermute, du willst dich dort bewerben.
Ich gehe nicht davon aus, dass du in der Otto-Personalabteilung arbeitest.
Wobei das auch witzig wäre, wenn sich die Otto-Personalabteilung anhören würde, was irgendein random Kerl auf Twitch dazu sagt.
Wenn das der Fall ist, dann sollte ich wirklich langsam Consulting-Sachen dafür verlangen.
Otto ist eines der erfolgreichsten...
Okay, das nervt mich immer ultra ab.
Ich meine, hallo?
Das ist eine komplette Seite Selbstlobpreisung.
Erst mal am Anfang, das juckt doch.
Keine Sau.
Um jetzt mal böse zu sein.
Also es juckt doch niemand, Alter.
Ich werde das jetzt mal, ich werde das jetzt skippen, das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an.
Mach auch du...
Du, Otto, zu deinem Playground.
Wir entwickeln jeden Tag mit Leidenschaft für den Marktplatz otto.de
Ganz schöner Otto, die Anzeige.
Dinge ausprobieren, neu denken, innovativ sein, aber sich über sich hinaus machen.
Das ist unser Mindset.
Richtiges High-Performer-Crinder-Mindset.
Lass uns gemeinsam etwas Großes erreichen.
Egal, ob du das Kampo...
In maximaler Qualität.
Mit voller Fehler.
Transparenz und komplett unabhängig vom technischen Stand des jeweiligen Partners.
Konkret bauen.
Treiben wir alle User-Interfaces und Application und APIs immer mit vollem Fokus auf die Bedürfnisse der Partner.
Da wir unseren Service auf sehr viele Partner und Produkte auslegen, setzen wir auf eine moderne Event-getriebene High-Performance-Architektur.
Da werden Events gesourced wahrscheinlich.
CQ...
Wie heißt dieser Krempel?
C-Q-R-S oder so?
Auch so ein Buzzword, wo sie zur Zeit voll draufstehen.
Viele sprechen von Homeoffice, wir von Mobile Work.
Davon sprechen auch viele.
Aber das finde ich gut, dass das direkt hier Anklang findet und Erwähnung findet in der Stellanzeige.
Unsere Teams entscheiden für sich, welche Gleichgewicht ausmobil...
Ah, okay.
Muss das quasi...
Muss da mit seinem Chef eins sein.
Ja, das ist auch...
Das ist auch eine gute, finde ich, ist eine gute Regelung.
Ist bei uns dort, wo ich aktuell arbeite, tatsächlich auch so.
Die haben eine ziemlich gute Homeoffice-Regelung, auch mit Betriebsrat und Unterschrift und allem drunter.
Aber letztendlich müssen die Teams die individuelle Regelung, also wie es für das Team gilt, nochmal genau absprechen.
Und das ist echt gut.
Funktioniert wunderbar.
Ist Mobile Work nicht so rechtliche Absicherung, damit man kein Equipment bereitstellen muss?
Kann schon sein.
Oh.
Na, eben habe ich gerade ins Mikrofon gepustet.
Ich habe gerade gemacht...
Geht es wieder?
Oder habe ich es...
Habe ich am Mikrofon gebraked?
Nee, habe ich nicht.
Du kannst gerne auch in Teilzeit...
Das ist gut.
Würde mich direkt ansprechen.
Ihr wisst...
Ich bin...
Teilzeit...
Ich arbeite Teilzeit seit Jahren schon.
Mehrere Sekunden lang.
Okay.
War bei euch auch mehrere Sekunden lang das Mikrofon weg?
Oder ist...
Oder ist Vodafone wieder am rumspacken?
Nö.
Knacken.
Ich verstehe das nicht.
Warum das manchmal knackt und manchmal nicht?
Ich verstehe es nicht.
Aber es ist ja in manchen Streams...
In manchen Streams ist es gar nicht, gell?
Und in seltenen Fällen ist es manchmal.
Also es ist sehr merkwürdig.
Windows.
Keck, keck Windows.
Weil viele Streams, die letzten paar Streams, haben wir da gar nichts, Leute.
Komisch.
Windows, Windows, shit.
Vielleicht habe ich auch einfach zu viele Tabs offen.
Hast du nicht in 20 Jahren einen Klinkenadapter?
Doch, doch, doch, habe ich.
Aber das widerspricht sich dem, dass es mal ist und dann wieder 10 Streams nicht.
Also unser Tech-Stack.
Java, Python, MongoDB, Spring.
Ja, Java-Zeug und Spring.
Also hier gerade Business Enterprise Sachen auf Spring stehen total.
React, AWS, Microservices, Serverless.
Und Event-Sourcing, habe ich es mir doch schon fast gedacht.
Hast du einen Kompressor an?
Ja, glaube ich, dass ich den noch anhabe.
Moment.
Aber daran wird es ja nicht liegen.
Wo ist das jetzt nochmal?
Filters.
Ja, bisschen, bisschen komprimiert.
Kompressiert.
Dein Impact.
Dein Impact, das hört sich ja schon wieder an.
So, das hört sich so Agile an.
Du agierst als DevOps-Engineer für Komponenten für Import und Verifikation von Artikeldaten der Partner.
Okay.
Du sorgst für Softwarequalität mit Clean-Code und Test-Automatisierung.
Du betreibst mit uns zusammen unsere Komponenten.
Das ist alles auch äußerst vage.
Microservices mit Rest, kann alles sein.
Serverless, ja gut.
Wahrscheinlich dann Lambda ist es unter AWS, oder?
Ein bisschen mehr technische Details, was genau, wäre schon irgendwo noch interessant.
Ach hier, kommt noch.
Kenntnisse von AWS mit möglichst vielen, mit vielen der Frameworks.
Leute, Amazon-Benahmung.
Seriously.
Also Route 53 ist der Cloud-DNS von AWS.
Der Name ist irgendwie ganz witzig.
Weil Port 53 und DNS und sowas.
Aber, also ich habe bei AWS mit Abstand die größten Probleme, am Hand des Namens zu erkennen, wofür was da ist.
Ja, ich wollte gerade sagen, Kühlschrank, Kühlschrank-Modellbezeichnung.
ALB, EC2, ja das ist, weil Amazon alles Elastic nennt.
Fargate, Fargate habe ich schon wieder vergessen.
Da wusste ich mal, was es ist.
Ah, die Serverless-Engine.
Ich dachte, Lambda ist die Serverless-Engine.
Ach, was auch immer.
Hast du die Geschichte mitgekriegt von dem geklauten Masterkey?
Klar.
Ah, wie geil.
S-N-S-S-Q-S-S-3.
Okay, S3 ist tatsächlich das zweite nach Route 53, wo ich sofort wusste, was es ist.
Wisst ihr, Chat, wisst ihr, wofür S3 steht?
Also S3 ist Storage, Cloud-Storage.
Beziehungsweise das Protokoll zum Cloud-Storage, Abfragen und Pushen.
Es war auch eines der allerersten Cloud-Geschichten, S3.
S3 habe ich mir mal gemerkt, wofür das steht.
Das ist tatsächlich recht simpel.
Simple Storage Service, genau.
Mit der S3 nach Bad Sohn im Taunus, korrekt.
Dafür steht S3 in AWS.
Erfahrung mit Docker und Terraform, gute Anforderung.
Erfahrung mit Python, okay.
Beherrschung des Betriebssystems Linux, auch gut.
Deutsch, nicht verkehrt.
Nice to have möglichst viel aus AWS.
Moment, was?
Ach, Datenbanken.
Möglichst viele aus AWS.
Aurora, Postgres, MongoDB.
Kenntnisse von GitHub Actions, GoCD, haben wir nicht benutzt.
Grafana, Java und Spring, Rest-Architektur-Skills.
Erfahrung mit Event-Sourcen, Kenntnisse von der Technologie wie React.
Agiles Crimeset, High-Performer-Mindset.
Idealerweise mit Kanban oder Scrum.
Work-Life-Balance.
Und Altersversorgungsmodelle.
Fachliche und persönliche Entwicklung.
Die wollen auch Java springen, ja.
Ach, ist doch egal.
Ich meine, ich habe mir so viele Sachen geschrieben.
Die suchen eigentlich einen, der sich wahrscheinlich um automatisierte Deployments und AWS-Infrastruktur kümmert.
Da würde ich jetzt gar nicht mal so viel drauf geben, ob es jetzt hauptsächlich Java-Anwendungen sind, Python-Anwendungen.
Das ist wurscht.
Weil es hier wahrscheinlich eher darum geht, dass die irgendwelche Automatisierung mit Python machen.
Weil ihre Anwendungen halt zum größten Teil in Java und Spring gebaut sind.
Also Java und Spring-Boot gebaut sind.
Zweiwöchentliches Onboarding, Masterplan, Coaching, Mentoring, Gesundheit, Wohlbefinden, Kultur und Zusammenhalt, Mobilität.
Ja, ganz ehrlich, Leute.
Klingt gar nicht schlecht.
Weiß ich, wer es war, wer sich darauf werben wollte.
Aber ich finde, klingt nicht schlecht.
Was ich halt immer übelst nervig finde, ist, wenn sie erstmal einen halben Roman schreiben, warum sie die geilsten sind.
So wirklich interessant ist eigentlich nur das hier.
Die erste Seite, Text, hätte man sich schränken können.
Ja, finde ich nicht schlecht.
Ich denke, wenn das was für einen ist, kann man sich da, wenn man sich davon angesprochen fühlt, kann man sich da bewerben.
Ich muss sagen, auf mein Profil passt es nur so zu, sagen wir mal, 80%.
Ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich der krasse Java-Checker wäre.
Python geht ganz gut, MongoDB, naja.
Ich kenne mich halt ziemlich gut mit Linux aus.
Ich kenne mich auch ziemlich gut mit...
Docker Terraform, Containerisierung, Kubernetes und so Zeug aus.
Von AWS nicht so wahnsinnig planer.
Also bei mir wird es nur so, sagen wir mal, zu 70, 80% passen.
Aber ansonsten, ich finde es nicht schlecht.
Klingt gut.
Wenn auch das Intro halt wieder bla bla bla.
Go CD und danach folgt der Go DVD.
Und danach kommt Go Blu-Ray.
Ich habe nichts verpasst.
Ein Junior Penetration Tester.
Wobei, habe ich das hier nicht schon aufgemacht?
Ne.
Jetzt sind wir zu Ende.
Wow, das ist ja eine fancy Webseite.
Guck mal hier.
Das ist ein irgendwie cooler, wenn auch massiv sinnloser Effekt.
Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, ob ich das gut oder schlecht finden soll.
Ich glaube, ich finde es gut.
Ich meine, der Effekt ist, glaube ich, relativ simpel gemacht.
Das ist eine CSS-Transition.
Oder einfach den Winkel ein bisschen anpassen.
Ich glaube, der Effekt ist einfach...
Es ist relativ simpel, aber gut.
Ich finde es eigentlich ganz cool.
Ach so, die Farbe.
Die Farbe liegt an meinem Darkreader.
So sieht die Webseite normalerweise aus.
Ist das überhaupt ein Unterschied jetzt?
Bisschen, bisschen.
Hat was von Wobbly Windows, ja.
Let's go.
Also, Diva E.
Den Namen kenne ich.
Ich bilde mir ein, ich hatte mit dem schon mal irgendwo was zu tun.
Was machen die denn so?
Der Name kommt mir bekannt vor.
Auto?
Woher kommt mir das denn bekannt vor?
Was machen die denn?
Keine Ahnung.
Woher kommen die mir bekannt vor?
Ich habe genau noch den Wortlaut im Kopf, wo irgendwie einer gesagt hat, das macht Diva E.
Oder Diva E?
Diva E?
Vielleicht gibt es noch andere Sachen, die sich so verändern.
Die sich so ähnlich anhören.
Aber irgendwann hatte ich mit dem schon mal was zu tun.
Oder?
Zumindest im größeren Rahmen jetzt.
Gut.
Also.
Diva E ist Deutschlands führender Transactional Experience Partner.
TXP.
Natürlich, Leute.
Sie sind immer alle führend.
Okay, langsam. Der Effekt ist nervig.
Mit dem Ball.
Der Rest ist cool, aber der Effekt ist nervig.
Was ist ein Transactional Experience Partner?
Der digitale Erlebnisse schafft.
Die Unternehmen nachhaltig voranbringen.
Blablabla.
Mit der geballten Erfahrung aus über 20 Jahren realisieren wir blablabla.
Okay, wir müssen mal zu den eigentlichen Sachen kommen.
Die haben einige Banken als Kunden.
Das ist durchaus möglich.
Wo steht denn das?
Partner.
Gucken wir mal.
Okay, also.
Was suchen denn?
Zur Verstärkung unseres Teams suchen wir dich als Senior System Engineer.
Für die interne IT Infrastruktur mit DevOps Mindset Invit.
Das ist genau das Richtige für mich.
Bloß nicht in München.
Und außerdem suche ich auch gerade keinen Job.
Aber, Leute.
Also.
Wir haben das High Performer DevOps.
Nicht nur DevOps, Leute.
Wir haben das High Performer Win bis Sec bis DevOps Mindset.
An den Standorten Karlsruhe, Jena, München, Berlin.
Sorgt unsere interne IT für die Reise.
Aktuell sind wir 13 Leute aufgeteilt auf zwei Teams, die für die interne IT fördern.
Das Team Zentrale Infrastruktur stellt die Verfügbarkeit weiter mit aller zentralen internen IT Systeme sicher.
Und hat den Fokus auf Themen wie Security und Automatisierung.
Eigentlich genau das, was mir Spaß macht.
Du wirst Teil dieses Teams sein.
Das klingt als ein dro patrol-Satz
Ohne Bezug zu davor und danach.
Ach so meinen die das?
Ok
Es gibt 2 Teams.
Du wirst Teil des Teams.
Das würde ich anders schreiben.
Wird das Team etwas mit User Support an wouldn't be.
suchen das wäre das wäre nichts für mich die abstimmung über die task erfolgs
standortbekämpfung via videokonferenz dank kanban boards aus super agil
diagonal skaliert weimar moderne für den sub haben wir die aufgaben und deren
fortschritte immer im blick salto fliegt danke für den sap habe ich nicht gesehen
ob ich doch habe ich gesehen jetzt wo ich ausgesprochen habe kann man board
haben wir die aufgeschrieben im blick im mittelpunkt unserer arbeit stehen
immer unsere diva kollegen die war eh kollegen ich war ich komme nicht drauf
wo ich mit denen schon mal was zu tun hatte die turn in die halb unbezahlbar
aber nur echt mit animier link im profilbild weiter oben im text stehen
die unternehmen davon ist nichts dabei gewesen hier fc bayern münchen die karls
heißt edeka ok wann kommt denn jetzt eigentlich was sie genau wollen was du
bei uns machst okay
ok
, du etablierst und vereinheitlicht prozesse in der regel selbstständig oder
mit unterstützung einer kollegen aus der internen IT
ok ja aber weiß ja nicht was sie sich genau darunter vorstellen ein themengebiet
mit dem wir uns aktuell intensiv beschäftigt information security ja ihr
wollt nicht dass irgendwelche sachen geliebt werden verständlicherweise
zusätzlich erarbeitet zu neuen konzepte und lösungen und setzt diese um wie so
ziemlich jeder job
ok die themen active directory
keck windows developers developers active directory ldap azure ad microsoft 365 intune
no no god please no no no no
linux für server
ok
deiner täglichen arbeit das ist ein richtiger voll ein kompletter full stack senior system
engineer er das vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben oder also ging jetzt sage ich
nix gegen monitoring sage ich nix gegen ansatz sage ich nix aber das windows netzwerk und linux
täglich zu gleichermaßen dafür statt also das ist ausgeschlossen da jemand zu finden den man
sich leisten kann es sei denn es steht einfach nur drin und in wirklichkeit gibt es schwerpunkte er
du hilfst uns den technischen support für die von uns erstellt auch noch support machen monka
es wird ja immer schlimmer da hätte ich keinen bock drauf dokumentation
das braucht man nur wenn man fehler macht wisst ihr doch so wie das umsetzen von projekten okay
bisschen projektmanagement auch noch guck mal recht geht weiter du bist ein echter team player
einer für alle alle für ein das ist dein und unser motto du hast bereits einige jahre erfahrung in
it teams und mit infrastruktur sowie der administration von unternehmensumgebung
darüber hinaus kennst du dich mindestens eines der betriebssysteme windows mac os oder linux aus dem
ff
mac os hätte ich jetzt immer gar nicht hierin gesehen an der stelle den attacken stack beherrscht
du im schlaf und hast diesen idealerweise auch als administrator bereits aufgesetzt okay kommt
hier doch dabei kann man aber mal als anforderung haben wenn wirklich das halbe unternehmen irgendwie
auf adolescent tools passiert war not du verfügst über gute kenntnisse in den bereich es geht noch
weiter es geht nach das hat es reicht oder es geht auch weiter die die die muss ich mir speichern die
Du verfügst über gute Kenntnisse in den Bereichen Inventarisierung, VPN, Kibana, Grafana, Prometheus, Web-Server, Datenbanken, IT-Security-Prinzipien, E-Mail-Stack, DNS und agile Methoden gehören für dich zum Alltag.
Wenn es sonst nichts ist, kein Problem, kein Ding, easy.
Du bist kommunikationsstark und hast für deine Kollegen stets ein offenes Ohr.
Wenn ich das alles machen muss, da habe ich für niemanden ein offenes Ohr, da bin ich froh, dass alles halbwegs irgendwie läuft oder Chatfenster und da du stets den Überblick behältst und in dir selbst ruhst, bringt es dich auch nicht aus dem Tritt, wenn es parallel Themen und Projekte gibt.
Ja, eher klar, ja natürlich, alles klar.
Schön wäre es, wenn du bereits Erfahrungen mit wachsenden, größeren Unternehmen und ihren IT-Prozessen, Systemen sammeln konntest.
Aber ich habe ein paar Fragen zu dir, die ich gerne noch nicht beantworten kann.
Ich habe ein paar Fragen zu dir, die ich gerne noch nicht beantworten kann.
Ah, jetzt, viel besser.
Was du von uns hast, deine Erfolgsmomente sind unsere Inspiration.
Wichtig, erstmal ein paar Post-its an die Tafel.
Ist die Frage, ob das überhaupt ein Bild ist von denen oder ob das irgendein Stockfoto ist.
Okay.
Wir legen sehr hohen Wert auf einen freundschaftlichen Kollegen, aber auch ehrlichen.
Okay, Ellenbogen, ich finde das Projekt bringt neue, spannende Herausforderungen.
Wir wissen, dass wir das erfolgreiche, blablabla, das gemeinsame Arbeiten austürfteln, umdenken, umsetzen, optimieren, macht uns Spaß, bei uns gewinnt die beste Idee und deine sind dir sehr, okay.
Das sagen sie alle, ob es dann am Ende so ist, haben wir dahingestellt.
Deine Work-Life-Balance nehmen wir sehr ernst.
Wie gesagt, sagen können das auch alle.
Viele von uns haben gerade eine Familie gegründet oder ein zeitintensives Hobby.
Ja gut, ein zeitintensives Hobby dürfte erstmal sein, sich einzuarbeiten in VPN, Kibana, Grafana, Prometheus, Web-Server, Datenbanken, E-Mail-Stack, DNS und agile Methoden.
Eventuell auch noch in Git, Netzwerk, Jamf, Linux-Server, Windows, LDAP, Azure, Microsoft Office 365 und Intune und Monitoring.
Das ist tatsächlich ein zeitintensives Hobby.
Jamf, Alter, was ein Name.
Aber ihr wisst jetzt, es ist Apple, es ist Apple Device Management.
Wir glauben, dass ausgeglichene...
...Mitarbeiter das Team deutlich weiterbringen, als wenn wir ihn überstunden aufbürden.
Daher sagen sie auch alle, du passt zu uns, dann bewirb dich jetzt.
IT-Themen und Projekte sind deine Leidenschaft.
Wenn die Arbeit zufrieden sind...
Naja.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob man das so ernst nehmen kann.
Also, es könnte durchaus sein.
Aber das ist ja nicht unsere Aufgabe, als jemand, der die Stellenanzeige liest.
Was soll denn dieser blaue Ball?
Die sind halt modern, krasses Webdesign.
Also, das Ding ist halt die.
Ist halt das.
Diese Stellenanzeige sagt nichts darüber aus, ob das ein guter Laden oder ein schlechter Laden ist.
Das können wir aber nicht beurteilen.
Wir müssen es ja anhand der Stellenanzeige irgendwie einordnen, ob man sich da drauf bewerben möchte oder nicht.
Und das ist umgedreht genauso.
Ja.
Eine Bewerbung.
Alleine sagt noch nichts wirklich abschließend darüber aus, ob das nicht vielleicht doch ein guter Bewerber ist oder nicht.
Aber du kannst es halt erstmal nur anhand der Bewerbung einschätzen.
Es ist durchaus möglich, dass die Personalabteilung eine Stellenanzeige zusammengezimmert hat.
Und von allen Seiten irgendwelche Fachbegriffe über den Zaun geworfen bekommen hat, die sie alle irgendwie verarbeitet haben.
Aber, wenn wir das jetzt mal rein an der Stellenanzeige messen, wie es da steht.
Also, die Themenverarbeitung.
Vielfalt ist komplett der Witz.
Was man da alles abdecken soll.
Wenn der Szenier ernst ist.
Ja.
Ähm.
Der Rest geht schon in Ordnung.
Wollen wir die Gehälter nochmal checken?
Können wir machen.
Die haben eine ziemlich gute Bewertung.
Die haben eine ganz gute Bewertung.
Von Top-Arbeit geht er, geht er zum Flop.
Okay.
Lass uns mal Gehälter gucken.
Weiß man halt nicht, ob das stimmt.
Wie, wie, aber, ja.
Scheint, scheint von.
So ungefähr hinzukommen.
Ja.
Ich mein, die Typen wissen sofort, um wen es geht, ne?
Also, hat man ja gesehen.
Also, ich weiß nicht.
Das will ich so auch nicht schreiben.
Also, man liegt wahrscheinlich eher in dem Bereich hier, dass es halt viel zu wenig für das, was die haben wollen.
Das wäre schon eher das in der Richtung.
Ja.
Kann man jetzt, kann man jetzt nix, nix sagen.
Also, ja, also, gerade das, was die an, was die an, an Themengebieten haben wollen, ist halt schon.
Nicht sonderlich realistisch, ja.
Aber ganz davon abgesehen, das hat man ja heute kaum noch nötig, ne?
Was willst du verdienen, bei wie vielen Stunden die Woche?
Da hab ich mir jetzt keine Gedanken zu gemacht.
Ich hab ja einen Job und bin damit jetzt auch aktuell, ich bin im fünften Probemonat, so weit zufrieden, dass ich nix Neues such.
Hallo, Chat, ich will loscrollen.
Ja, ich finde, das sollte man, sollte man schon besser formulieren.
Wir hatten hier auch schon die ein oder anderen richtig guten Stellenanzeigen, wo ich mir gedacht hab,
ey, das sticht mal richtig raus, so.
Ja, korrekt.
So, einen haben wir noch.
Wird auch langsam knapp hier mit der Zeit.
Also, einen können wir uns danach noch angucken, falls ihr noch was habt, Chat.
Sowohl, sowohl beide Seiten.
Wenn ihr euch irgendwo bewerben wollt, als auch wenn ihr Leute sucht, könnt ihr, könnt ihr beide schicken.
Aber für eine, für eine haben wir noch, eine haben wir noch Zeit.
Als was?
Als Senior Linux Engineer.
Aber Jobbezeichnungen sind eh da Schall und Rauch.
Ich kümmere mich aktuell.
Tatsächlich, ausgesprochen, ich meine, ich arbeite nur unter Linux, ja.
Aber es ist nicht so, dass ich sagen würde, Linux ist mein, mein, äh, arges Inhalt.
Aktuell bin ich hauptsächlich damit beschäftigt, Terraform-Sachen zu erstellen und mich um Kubernetes-Cluster in der Cloud zu kümmern.
Okay, ein Senior, nee, ein Junior war das hier.
Ein Junior.
Was wäre denn für euch das Minimum-Einschicksgeil als Anwendungsentwickler?
Da hatten wir, hatten wir letztens einen guten, guten, guten Wert gefunden im Chat.
Für die heutige Zeit.
Aber ich habe ihn wieder vergessen.
Deswegen kann ich dir das auch nicht mehr sagen.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, was es war.
Das war eine ganz gute Mischung aus dem, was einige Leute geschrieben haben.
Und, äh, was ich hochgerechnet habe.
Mein Einstiegsgehalt mit Inflation.
Gute Anlaufstelle, um mit Kubernetes anzufangen.
Eine Linux-VM mit Minikube drauf und dann drauf losbasteln.
Okay, also, was suchen die denn hier?
Sie suchen einen...
Sie suchen gar nichts, oder?
Sollte da nicht eigentlich jetzt irgendwo im Titel stehen, was die suchen?
Sie suchen einen Junior-Pentester oder sowas, weiß ich noch.
Also, durch die einzelnen Anwendungen, Web-Mobile-APIs nimmst du genau, äh, okay.
Das ist das Wort, was ich immer nicht aussprechen kann.
Sicherheitslücken.
Die von dir oder auch im Team durchgeführten Risikoeinschätzungen, Handlungsempfehlungen, sowie deine Dokumentation helfen unseren Kunden und Kunden auch mit Komplettkontakt.
Was ist denn das Personalvermittlungsladen?
Make Forward.
Hä, das ist bestimmt irl... So ein...
Was bin ich sehend?
Ja, das ist irgend' so'n Dienstleistungsladen wahrscheinlich.
Je nach deinem persönlichen Schwerpunkt...
demise
zu später auch okay das heißt die bringen ja auch noch ein bisschen was bei mobile apps
iot devices auto krempel benefits jobrat zahle zertifizierung flexible arbeitszeiten wie sieht
es mit home office und firmen events aller qualifikation okay die wollen unbedingt den
studierten haben okay nichts oder vergleichbare nein es muss jemand seiner studiert aber okay
ich meine dürfen die bezahlen sie dürfen nach dem fragen was sie wollen du beherrschst bereits
eine folge skript oder programmier sprachen javascript heißen schild skript java sp.net
cc++ das hat wieder jemand geschrieben der keine ahnung hat von dem was es da um was es da geht ja
also wer das so schreibt da siehst du sofort dass er keine ahnung hat was er schreibt außerdem
ist asp.net keine programmier sprache sondern asp.net wird meistens die schar programmiert und
asp.net ist auch outdated ja gut also deswegen so ein personaldude der das geschrieben hat er nicht
weiß was er da hinschreibt die unterscheidung zwischen skript und programmier sprachen finde
ich ja immer ein bisschen beknackt aber da will ich mich jetzt nicht drüber auslassen das ist
noch das kleinste ding gänge betriebssysteme applikationen web und netzwerktechnologien
linux windows server router firewalls cloud iot okay bam deine leute
leidenschaft für pentesting ist sichtbar durch teilnahme an ctr das finde ich eine gute sache
ja finde ich auch dass man muss ja irgendwie halbwegs einschätzen können ob die leute dann
hang dazu haben ja denken und erzählen können dass viele ja das finde ich gut dass da so was drin
steht github projekte ja ja finde ich finde ich eine gute sache dass die darauf wert legen kurz
und knackig finde ich gut dass die stellanzeigen kurz und knackig ist nicht so viel bla bla
ja ansonsten attraktives gehalt sagen auch alle finde ich gar nicht schlecht finde ich nicht übel
kann man sich kann man sich denke ich bewerben schön schön kurz und knackig auch wenn der
personaler der das hier geschrieben hat echt keine ahnung davon hat was er geschrieben hat
aber gut leider stadt mit home office dasteht oder das natürlich blöd aber wenn das irgend so
eine beratungsbude ist oder vermittlungsbude dann werden die das auch nicht anbieten da muss man halt
wissen worauf man sich einlässt hat es gar nicht so schlecht wie gesagt ich würde mich nicht drauf
bewerben weil bei mir ist erstens teilzeit zweitens will ich eine hohe home office anteil so habe ich
irgendwelche stellanzeigen übersehen eine noch ok software developer microsoft power plattform
specialist das ist ja gar nichts für mich nicht schlimm die meisten stellanzeigen heute werden
gar nichts für mich gewesen aber
microsoft windows zeug und plattform specialist ich dachte da unten kommt jetzt ein button für cookies
und so der ist aber glaube ich kaputt der cookie button dafür müssen wir sagen ist die seite
blazingly fast written in rust backend bestimmt was ist das auf was passiert das plain plain
javascript erkennen wir ist das wordpress erkennen wir irgendwelche überbleibsel
was das ist also die übernahme wandel manifest jason das ist mobile steht wie heißt dieses ding
da gibt es doch so eine ja bild wird so was in der richtung so was in der richtung was wap leiser
exzellent scheiß drauf
perangскreta
inwiefern ist auf
sehr visitiert aber wirklich in was sie das gebaut haben
in was könnten die das gebaut haben
значит
obstendig
Photoshop Fazit
Festival
is this forward
angie ist das ist das einzige
also am text에g das habe ich gesucht
oder so go to the perfect
ist react placing fast hier frontend seite okay also was suchen sie denn ist
ein software developer mbd microsoft power platform specialist sie brennen
für die programmierung möchten maßgeschneiderte an es gibt doch
irgendwo so einen es gibt doch bestimmt schon in den chat bot in den chat gpt
prompt mit dem man solche introsätze generieren kann oder die lesen sich
teilweise so ähnlich sie brennen für die programmierung möchten maßgeschneidert
applikation auf basis der mächtigen microsoft power plattform entwickeln
genau das ich wache morgens auf und denke mir auch alter ich würde so gern
maßgeschneiderte mächtige anwendungen entwickeln auf microsoft power
plattform basis um ihr wissen mit innovativen dann kommen sie zu uns zum
ausbau unseres agilen entwicklerteams suchen wir sie als engagierte wissens
durstige und ford von den möglichkeiten moderner software begeisterter
persönlichkeit in drei wollen sie es aber wissen er auf basis
moderner
programmiersprache was ist das das sind vb 6 noch okay also zeigt man ja ihre
rolle entwicklung innerhalb und mit der microsoft was ist denn eigentlich die
microsoft power plattform ich habe da so kein plan von power bi ist das das habe
ich schon ein paar mal gehört und nicht gerade positiv modellierung daten
strukturen die eingestaltung sie schafft plugins ok x eine sache javascript
benutzerdefinierte schnittstellen web entwicklung unter sprachen wie sie schafft
und javascript einfach entwickeln kunden nach den devops prinzip jetzt
gesucht ein paar das ist auch bitte das hat auch schon ein bisschen zu viel
oben drüber wieder oder bisschen bisschen zu viel anderes zeug dabei wenn
bereitstellen eigentlich betreuen von kundenprojekten nach dem der fonds
prinzip gut sie beherrschen mindestens eine objektorientierte programmierst
man ja praktisch erfahren bereich der entwicklung berufsausbildung fachinformatik
jahr für anwendungsentwicklung abgeschlossen studium sind empathisch
nutzer hineinversetzen diese sie haben durch was uns besonders macht
einarbeitungsphase offene arbeitsumgebung dass die rit club
office also quasi eine art großraumbüro discover the spirit of excellence
modernste it-ausstattung auch für mobile office flasche erschienen familiäre werte
nach der gibt's link zu kono vielleicht ja ich glaube machst du das öfters jahr so
einmal im monat also ich glaube so schlecht ist es gar nicht es ist einfach
nur nicht für mich dem entsprechend also ich fühle mich dadurch nicht
angesprochen aber das liegt einfach daran weil es überhaupt nicht meine
themengebiete sind es ist jetzt nicht super überragende stellenanzeige wo ich
sage geil da ist aber hier die bewerbung raus wie gesagt ich so regal job aber
ich habe auch schon weit schlechteres gesehen zu der microsoft geschichte kann
ich halt nicht sagen dass hier unten finde ich dann vielleicht ein bisschen
viel er auf der einen seite suche sind entwickler aber jetzt soll er auch
gleichzeitig und betriebs machen und kundenprojekte organisieren aber der rest
geht glaube ich voll in ordnung wir haben outlook auf der arbeit ich
benutze outlook nicht ich habe einfach text files mit meinen notizen drinne
fertig und wenn ich outlook benutzen muss dann nach möglichkeit web outlook
okay ein einkommen zu angucken oder weil momo wenn du wenn du schnell bist können
wir das heute noch machen also zehn minuten hätte ich noch zehn minuten
können wir noch schnell zu angucken dann würde ich jetzt da würde ich jetzt
also wenn du wenn es die schon gibt ansonsten war das nächsten monat ich
meine nichts das muss nicht nächsten monat sein es kann auch sein dass ich den
zwei drei wochen der meinung bin da jetzt könnte man will habe ich wieder
bock drauf haben wir denn hier ein okay schon mal eine angenehme seite was ohne
dark reader nicht komplett blendet dm gruppe ein linux system engineer
wenigstens wo ich was zu sagen kann und die sind alle so glücklich hier
da war auch so ein fotograf in irgend so einem daily und er hat gesagt jetzt
dreht euch doch mal um und lacht und alle ihr freund und so dass
wir haben tafel stehen dürfen und zeug drauf heften administration zentral
linux server umgeben oder wenn ich glaube das muss man copy copy pasten software
entwickler c-sharp okay aber auch gleich reingucken bei uns aber das war
es für heute die webseite ist mega lahm wie war das mit first first time to
render und sowas aber gucken wir erstmal ihren zentralen linux server red hat so
dass kummern bis jetzt hat das doch gar nicht schlecht aus dieser anzeige aber
suse
weiterentwicklung unserer automatisierung aus sie cdn simple
palpatine web wunderbar passt gut zusammen beratung troubleshooting
gemeinsam mit produkt auch vollkommen gut gut und passend dafür monitoring
performance optimierung unsere linksysteme
ging ja ich weiß nicht mehr das nicht auf
ElasticStack, Prometheus, auch gute Sachen, mitgestalten von IT-Projekten, das bringst du mit, abgeschlossenes Studium, Informatikbezug, okay, Erfahrung mit Umgang mit Linux, IT-Security-Verständnis, Container, Orchestrierung, Dogger, Kubernetes, Programmiersprachen, Shell, Python, Ruby, Interesse an Open Source, finde ich gut, dass das drin steht, ja, gut, Leute, das ist eine gute Stellenanzeige, die gefällt mir,
also, wie gesagt, bin ich auf der Suche nach einem Job, kurz und knackig, mit den passenden Stichpunkten drin, natürlich könnte es immer noch ein bisschen geiler sein, aber die geht in Ordnung, die finde ich gut, jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, ob das Gehalt passt, Homeoffice wäre auch noch eine interessante, überwiegend mobil im Arbeiten, wunderbar, ja, klingt gut, klingt nicht schlecht,
guck mal, DM hat sogar ein GitHub,
Shitter-Account, was haben die da so, Lisa, Lovely Interface for Sys-Admins, ne, das ist ein Formen-UI, verwenden die Puppet, Formen ist, glaube ich, für Puppet, Sort nach Stern, erinnere mich ein bisschen an meinen alten Arbeitgeber, die hatten auch Formen und Puppet, okay, nicht so viel Spannendes da,
okay, dann widmen wir uns jetzt mal der digitalen Revolution,
die Farben erinnern mich ein bisschen an die Jetbrains-Logos, der hat schon mal richtig hier, Hochkant, Notebook und noch ein Curved, und was hat er offen, das, was zum, ist das Hollywood, was er im Hintergrund laufen hat, ne, ne, der hat tatsächlich irgendwas, was Sinnvolles laufen, glaube ich, ja, der Stuhl ist wirklich viel zu niedrig, aber gut, meine, jeder wie er will,
was hat er da, ist,
das ist Hollywood, was er laufen hat im Hintergrund, das ist Hollywood, hier ist C-Matrix, Leute, das ist, das, die haben Hollywood im Hintergrund, das ist, wer das, zur Erklärung, wer das nicht kennt, es gibt ein Tool unter Linux, das nennt sich Hollywood, ich kann euch das mal, ich kann euch das mal zeigen, das heißt Hollywood, weil, das deine, dein Terminal so aussehen lässt, wie, halt in Filmen, wenn die, wenn sie am Hacken sind,
pass mal auf,
ich will das nicht installiert haben, weil, das ist, hat 30 Milliarden Dependency, ist, deswegen,
hups,
mach ich einen Snapshot und resette den dann gleich wieder dafür,
das ist das, was der Typ im Hintergrund laufen hat,
guck mal, ein Terminal kackt sogar ab bei,
das hat er im Hintergrund laufen,
guckt,
da sieht man hier ein C-Matrix und sowas,
ich glaube, ich hab's kaputt gemacht,
lustig,
okay,
Snapshot,
Reward,
und weg ist es wieder,
okay, also, lasst uns das mal angucken,
find ich schon mal sehr nice,
gibt bei mir schon mal Pluspunkte, dass er Hollywood im Hintergrund laufen hat,
vielleicht ist es auch nicht Hollywood,
vielleicht ist es auch dieses, das andere Tool,
es gibt auch ein Konkurrenzprodukt dazu,
hier oben hat er GitHub oder GitLab vom Logo,
eher GitLab oder so, auf,
guck dir den Dev an,
gut, vorankommen mit Rosos,
in ganz Deutschland begleiten wir Kommunen auf dem,
okay, das ist der Grund, warum das keiner machen will,
wir haben den Grund,
wir haben den Grund sofort schon gefunden,
da hat wahrscheinlich keiner Bock drauf,
egal wie gut die Firma ist,
als, Leon, danke für den Sub,
als Komplettanbieter liefern wir Lösungen aus einer Hand,
von der Software bis hin zur Beratung,
um die digitale Transformation in der kommunalen Verwaltung,
ich glaube, da hat keiner Bock drauf,
suchen wir für mehrere Teams,
Softwareentwickler C-Sharp,
verstärkt unser Team in der Geschäftsfeldern,
Bauen und Umwelt,
oder soziale Sicherung,
in Vollzeit mit Arbeitsort,
im Homeoffice oder in,
in Härten,
im Herzen des Ruhrgebiets,
und komme voran beim Marktführer für kommunale IT-Lösungen,
das wird dein Job,
du bist aktiv an der Entwicklung,
pflege andere Produkte beteiligt,
du stellst hochwertige technische Lösungen
auf Basis fachlicher Anforderungen,
du unterstützt die Product-Owner-Innen
bei der Analyse und Bearbeitung von Anfragen
mit Software-Technik,
mit technischem Hintergrund,
ist alles sehr vage, oder?
Du arbeitest in einem Scrum-Team,
du schreibst entwicklungsbegleitende Tests,
Leute, das neue Meta ist,
Entwickler zu suchen, die keine Tests schreiben,
weil ihre Sachen immer gleich funktionieren,
du entwickelst datenbankgestützte Oracle-MSSQL-Desktop-Anwendungen auf Power,
ich glaube, da haben heute wenige .NET-Entwickler wirklich noch Bock drauf,
auf WPF-Basis Uralt-Anwendungen zu pflegen,
das könnte natürlich auch sein,
dass das mit da reinspielt,
dass sich zu wenig Leute drauf bewerben.
Du arbeitest in einer modernen Entwicklungsumgebung,
abhängig vom jeweiligen Einsatzbereich bestehend aus,
Rider, sehr gut, .NET 4.8,
hat keiner mehr Bock drauf heute,
C++17, für Masochisten,
SVN, ach du Kacke,
Git, gut, NUnit, meinetwegen ReSharper,
ja, wenn es Visual Studio ist,
du nutzt nach Einsatzgebiet eine gut ausgestattete
CI-Umgebung aus GitLab oder TeamCity mit mehr als 100,
ich glaube, gibt es da mehrere Sachen,
das wünschen wir uns, du bringst eine, okay,
du besitzt eine Beruf, okay,
Unit-Test, C++, WTF,
WPF, aber auch WTF,
du konntest bereits Ersterfahrungen in GitLab oder TeamCity sammeln,
so denkst du vielleicht, du passt zu uns,
wenn die folgenden Sätze auch von dir stammen können,
okay, also Chat, wir überprüfen das jetzt mal,
ob ich passen würde, also,
würde ich diesen Satz sagen,
Qualität ist mir wichtig, um diese zu erreichen,
habe ich sowohl Produkt und Fachlichkeit,
als auch die Prozesse und das Umfeld im Blick,
okay, ich würde es vielleicht nicht so sagen,
aber ich finde, das ist gar nicht so verkehrt,
so, eine hohe Produktqualität
entsteht durch die Zusammenarbeit aller Beteiligten,
am ganzen Ergebnis, was,
eine hohe Produktqualität entsteht durch die Zusammenarbeit
aller Beteiligten, am ganzen Ergebnis
und kontinuierliche Verbesserung,
eine hohe Produktqualität entsteht dadurch,
dass man High-IQ-Leute hat,
hauptsächlich Leute mit Prime-Sub im Wubblos-Twitch-Chat,
ja, warum nicht, ist auch nicht so verkehrt,
Zusammenarbeit geht nur mit gegenseitiger Wertschätzung,
genauer und offener, ehrlicher Kommunikation,
okay, ja, die Weiterentwicklung unserer Produkte
möchte ich aktiv mitgestalten und Ideen einbringen,
okay, mir ist eine gut dokumentierte und strukturierte
Architekturübersicht für unsere Softwareprodukte wichtig,
ja, aber habt ihr wahrscheinlich nicht,
zumindest liest sich das so, als sind das halt ganz viele Legacy-Anwendungen,
gute Gründe für ProSOS, hohe Eigenverantwortung,
kurze Entscheidungswege, wertschätzendes viel Raum zum Ausprobieren,
flexible Arbeitszeitmodelle, mobil, das finde ich gut, dass es direkt drinne steht,
KillMeToWinGG, danke für den Sub,
Prog,
huge Subscription,
Home-Office-Möglichkeit deutschlandweit,
okay, unbefristig Arbeitsvertrag, attraktives Vergütungspaket,
umfassendes Rücktritts-Anbauten zum orientierten Ankommen, Netzwerk,
also, wahrscheinlich ist der Laden gar nicht schlecht,
irgendwie, ich kann euch nicht sagen, warum,
ja, die Stellanzeige haut mich jetzt auch nicht vom Hocker,
aber ich glaube, der Laden ist gar nicht schlecht,
das Einzige, was, also, warum, also, mal angenommen,
ich würde mich, ich würde mich als .NET-Entwickler dort bewerben,
ich kenne mich mit .NET ja ganz gut aus,
aber ich bin kein hauptberuflicher Anwendungsentwickler,
Mike, danke für den Sub, scroll nochmal ganz runter,
willst du die Personalmanagerin rangucken, oder was,
oder, warum soll ich runterscrollen, Gehalts-,
ach, also, hier muss man seine Gehaltsvorstellung angeben,
okay, also, ähm,
ja, die, die Webseite ist jetzt, ist jetzt nicht unbedingt,
die Webseite ist vor allem langsam as fuck, ja,
guck mal, jetzt ist es schnell, nee, die ist richtig langsam, Leute,
also, mit, mit der Webseite gewinnt ihr keinen Blumentopf hier,
ey, mal, guck mal, die Webseite lädt 6,5 Sekunden,
krass, Alter, das habe ich schon ewig nicht mehr gesehen,
besteht aus, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist,
ist das ne Webforms-Anwendung noch, jQuery?
Das wirkt sehr legacymäßig,
also, seriously, ich glaube, das ist gar nicht schlecht,
irgendwie sagt mir das mein Gefühl,
ich kann dann nicht, ich glaube, ich glaube, der Laden ist gar nicht so übel,
ähm, diese Sachen hier allerdings als modern zu verkaufen,
ist halt schon ein bisschen, ein bisschen weirdchamp,
ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es in dem Fall tatsächlich,
tatsächlich sogar besser ist weniger zu schreiben schreibt lieber die modernen sachen rein ich
meine ihr solltet die leute vielleicht nicht komplett gebeten wenn sie euch danach fragen
aber muss ich ja auch nicht schlechter darstellen als man letztendlich ist also ich würde dort 4.8
schon mal komplett raus schmeißen ich würde es vor allem schon mal komplett raus schmeißen ich
würde drinnen lassen visual studio und rider ob er jetzt ein unit verwendet und wie scharper
ist wurscht geht rein c++ kann meinetwegen drin sprengen svn raus .NET 8 raus rider visual studio
drin stehen lassen und vielleicht noch ein bisschen andere moderne sachen wenn ihr das
habt wenn ihr moderne wenn ihr moderne sachen habt wie höhenverstellbare schreibtische eine
kantine kinderbetreuung und was auch immer würde ich das auf jeden fall noch erwähnen
aber schmeißt schmeißt zumindest svn und .NET 4.8 raus und schreibt .NET Core rein falls ihr .NET Core
anwendungen habt wenn ihr halt keine .NET Core anwendungen habt ist halt da weißt du eigentlich
schon was ich erwarte dann würde ich wahrscheinlich nur noch .NET schreiben der anderen seite irgendwann
müsste die leute auch mal rein wein einschenken ja ist doch für bewerber gut wenn sie denkt so
wie das hier aktuell aussieht sieht es für mich aus als wurden dort anwendungen erstellt 2008 und
mehr oder weniger ja sind die halt immer noch da und du musst dich um anwendungen von 2008 kümmern
so liest sich das für mich wpf ist halt auch nicht mehr so der der hit gerade also das ist
so ein job wo ich mir vorstellen könnte den nimmt halten .NET entwickler an der der sich denkt so
eigentlich kein bock mehr mich mit etwas neuem zu beschäftigen in drei jahren gehe ich in rente
können wir noch machen was wahrscheinlich auch viele nicht schockt ist dass es ihr um
behörden zusammenarbeit mit behörden und kommunale sachen geht wobei das eigentlich ja gar kein
problem ist ihr seid ja der dienstleister dafür ihr seid ja nichts von also ihr seid ja schon ein
ganz normales privates unternehmen was halt dienstleistungen anbietet für kommunen oder
oder nicht oder seid ihr irgend so einen wie nennt man das so einen so einen abkömmlingen von
irgendeinem staatlichen ding dann ja dann ja da muss man sich mal ein bisschen auf die hülle legen
ja da muss man sich mal ein bisschen auf die hülle legen dann muss man sich mal ein bisschen auf die hülle legen
vielleicht ein bisschen besser verkaufen dass man eben nichts wirklich hier öffentlicher kram
ist sie sichere arbeitsplatz kann man sicherlich auch noch mal reinschreiben schwierig also ich
also vom gefühl her habe ich schon den eindruck also ehrlich gesagt hauptsächlich nur wegen dem
bild hier oben dass der typ hollywood auffahrt auf seinen lehnungskisten ja aber er vom gefühl
würde ich sagen dass er schlägt daran ist gar nicht übel ich weiß jetzt auch nicht wie man es ein bisschen
besser verkaufen könnte ich brauche einen neuen audioadapter ist wirklich so im arsch ja weil wartet
besser verkaufen könnte ich brauche einen neuen audioadapter ist wirklich so im arsch ja weil wartet mal so das liegt glaube ich nicht daran
mal so das liegt glaube ich nicht daran
mal so das liegt glaube ich nicht daran ich habe mich nicht bewegt gerade vielleicht
ich habe mich nicht bewegt gerade vielleicht
ich habe mich nicht bewegt gerade vielleicht habe ich auch wieder in obs zu viele zu
habe ich auch wieder in obs zu viele zu
habe ich auch wieder in obs zu viele zu viele sachen offen
viele sachen offen
viele sachen offen das müsste ich müsste das halt hier mal
das müsste ich müsste das halt hier mal
mitschneiden ist es ist es jetzt gerade aktuell leute ist es vielleicht wenn ich
irgendwie im browser groß rum scrolle oder reload irgendwie sowas in der
richtung jetzt ist nix top sagt sekunde vor alles mal raus die
ja keine ahnung was ich will wissen ob es an obs liegt oder an mikrofons
wahrscheinlich mikrofon selbst ich kann mir jetzt zu ehrlich gesagt nicht sagen
so aus dem stehgreif wie gesagt ich habe den eindruck der laden ist gar
nicht schlecht da müsste das irgendwie ein bisschen bisschen attraktiver
verkaufen ja aktuell würde ich halt aktuell denke
ich mir halt so okay ich bin dort nette entwickler gehen fünf jahre in rente und
sucht doch irgendwie war es dann dann würde ich mich auf sowas bewerben so
nach dem motto das ist eine sichere sache für fünf jahre ich kann das
benutzen was ich schon seit 20 jahren benutze da war es ja okay da war es ja
okay
so nach dem motto das ist eine sichere sache für fünf jahre ich kann das
benutzen was ich schon seit 20 jahren benutze hier ist doch gar nichts fünf
jahre in rente und sucht doch irgendwie war hier hier fünf jahre in rente und
sucht doch irgendwie was dann dann würde ich mich auf sowas bewerben so nach
falsche kilo nähe das wäre dann dauerhaft
aber chat das ist nicht jeden stream ich glaube ich muss einfach reboot und dann
das ist weg das ist das wird in windows scheiß sein
könnte ich wetten vielleicht liegt doch echt einmal im audio adapter an dem wird
also an meinem ach so film also am audio interface wird es nicht liegen neuer
rechner fuck ja wird mal wieder zeit geld auszugeben
na gut ich hoffe es hat sie trotzdem ein
bisschen geholfen wer war es denn etwas mit w am anfang
weimar mo
mir fällt ja nicht so wirklich mehr dazu ein ganz jahr nächsten monate noch mal
zeigen wenn sich was geupdatert hat da gucken wir rein
leute ich muss jetzt ins bett bett geteilt um buch schlafen das scheiße
sind die haarisse im main board jetzt zeigen sie sich langsam ich glaube wir
brauchen mal wieder auto musik kann das sein
auto musik heute bis zum nächsten mal macht's gut zu
See you.